[Music]
[Music]
there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey you guys yeah we're still in the
empty ass room
look how empty this [ __ ] room is and
it probably sounds really weird too echo
echo echo as you can see i've been
moving [ __ ] as you can see yeah yeah i
got more than half the house moved
yesterday you guys
he
loaded and unloaded two entire u-hauls
yeah pretty much all by yourself yeah i
kind of helped you with a few things you
had a dolly and stuff yeah yeah
refrigerators no not refrigerators i
wash and dryer
[ __ ] what else was it just all kinds
of [ __ ] just
randomly that [ __ ] your your weight
yeah bench weight benches all the
weights
[ __ ] i still got generators i got to
move i rode a motorcycle down there
today got another motorcycle sitting in
there and i got to take there just
transferring everything over there
yeah it's rough
it is yeah that's rough but most of the
stuff is most of the stuff jenny painted
the new studio yeah the color's good she
[ __ ] up one wall we're not going to
talk about that though well that's not
going to be the wall that you're going
to see on camera and i'm going to cover
it up with our anyway i didn't [ __ ] it
up
i knew it was going to be
what okay so what ended up happening
was that
i bought a gallon of the color that i
wanted which is called dark secret it's
almost black pretty much it's like a
really really dark really dark blue yeah
blue no gray yeah
um so i bought a gallon of that like
satin right and then i also bought
another quart of it because i was also
going to paint the bathroom cabinets
that same color
so then as i'm doing the room i'm like
[ __ ] this room is like actually a little
bit bigger than i thought and i started
running out of the satin so it's just
like [ __ ] it i'm going to have to use
the quart because i really want to
finish this and i just like won't be
able to paint the cabinets and so
the one wall like i said it'll be the
wall that that we're facing when we're
see you won't be able to see it on
camera but yeah it's a little bit patchy
just because because the cabinet paint
that i got was like uh semi-gloss or i
can't remember but uh yeah so it wasn't
the same
it wasn't the same glossiness yeah the
wall one yeah it looks wrong well i know
it's wrong but like i said i just wanted
to fit yeah i'll fix it and it's just
kind of like like i said that's not
going to be on camera anyway no so i'm
not like it just happens to be that that
window's right there and the light hits
it and you can see that glare it looks
like there's it looks like
parts of the paint are still wet yeah
that's what i mean it just looks like
patchy yeah um
uh tila's in the room yeah you just want
to show up i don't know so like as soon
as we come on talking about stuff it's
like the first thing you talk about is
the one thing that i [ __ ] up yeah all
the stuff that i did good i did it right
no it looks great
but now oh here's this one tiny thing
that you must have but that negates
every single thing that i was thinking
about oh yeah well if it's not
perfection then it's [ __ ] up
hey that's the way it works you painted
this house and i see smears all over the
[ __ ] so it's like don't get all over
it's like the same color though
every wall is the same color i didn't
use two colors all [ __ ] up you got it
like on the ceiling you got it on the
baseboard
you have to look closely though to see
that that's what i mean well and like i
said it's going to be covered up with
artwork anyway i just haven't put any
artwork up yet and i still had and i had
to get another set of curtains because i
thought when i ordered the curtains
i thought that it was four panels but
it's only two panels and i have two
windows so i had to order but they're
coming tomorrow the house is pretty cool
pretty big
um
we're gonna [ __ ] deck that upstairs
out man it's gonna look good yeah
eventually it's gonna take very little
tiles yeah we're gonna see we're gonna
see how it goes um
i like the area though
yeah it's kind of it's kind of rural you
know like we said before the way this
place was ten years ago
tila says are y'all setting up the new
studio in the same way or different
styles
it's different like the walls are way
way darker
and um i'm just gonna do i think like
behind where the camera is gonna be i'm
just gonna do like mostly a gallery wall
back there like because i have a [ __ ]
ton of
different artwork like different prints
and all kind of different stuff that i
want to put back there and i got two
bookshelves i got those today and tom
put them together yeah and uh so i'm
gonna go the books are just like stacked
on the floor right now so i got another
one i got another room that i'm i'm
gonna make it up my own studio and
workshop for certain things that i do
you know
uh working on stuff
and i may do it i may do a show from
there may do my own show from there
we'll see yeah women won't be invited
though it's just men only
[Laughter]
oh you're going to be all sexist about
it it's going to be it's going to be
sexist as [ __ ]
it's going to be like dudes only
dudes yeah dude
man i'm just i'm just making sure
but
it's gonna be it's kind of it's gonna be
[ __ ] uh
it's gonna be [ __ ] topics that i'm
into
you know what i mean
[ __ ] probably like guns and
[ __ ]
maybe battles
history [ __ ] philosophies and [ __ ]
[ __ ] commentary it'll be everything
i'll comment on anything
you know commentary on women just
whatever
we'll see how it goes
he's going to say all kind of terrible
[ __ ] up [ __ ] no
no no you know
i'm just i'm just [ __ ] paying
attention to what's happening on other
channels you know what i mean and they
got these millennial dudes man [ __ ]
those dudes are [ __ ] they're not
getting any dates man
they're not getting any dates it's like
it always was you know what i mean where
the women are all running after that top
15
but you know that's other [ __ ] you know
and i'm not into that [ __ ] big title
[ __ ] what they're talking about what
those guys talk about i don't believe it
you know i agree with it but you don't
resign yourself to that [ __ ] you fight
you fight back
you fight to win
okay if the girls don't we're not going
out with you it's because you you're
doing something wrong because you suck
yeah you're doing something wrong
you're doing something wrong
that's what well that's what kind of
cracks me up about them all those mgtow
people which is which is meant to blame
men going their own way yeah uh which by
the way which is funny because it's like
well thank well bye don't let the door
hit you in the ass on the way out yeah
just go your own way jenny gets mad
though whenever i mention that mgtow
[ __ ] i mean i don't i don't agree with
it
but when i mention it she's she gets mad
because women actually are like where
are you going you know
where you going what do you mean you
can't shut us off what do you mean you
don't want to deal with you know
and those dudes don't want to deal with
it you know i don't get mad they they
can go away i don't want to i don't want
to deal with them they are they don't
i just said i just think it's funny that
it's called that because i was just kind
of everyone's just like bye
yeah yeah no one's going oh please come
back then they pick on them though you
know they pick on them calling them
because it's funny you know they didn't
want to pick on them but it's it's a
funny can't force these dudes to deal
with you it's a funny enforcement no i
think it's funny because it's a funny
hill to die on you know what i mean
it what each one look why are we even
talking about this
you started it yeah i just was just
gonna let it go
you always he starts talking about a
topic and then like later on he's like
why the [ __ ] are we even talking about
this i'm like cause you said whatever
[ __ ] are we talking about because you've
started talking about it that's why
because you were talking about it
because you were talking about your
men's only show and i thought that was
very funny
[Laughter]
that that was [ __ ] if i say some [ __ ]
like that you you for sure these women
are going to be [ __ ] bombing that
show
[ __ ] with me in the comments i
wouldn't i don't care that much i'm not
gonna watch it yeah it's just gonna be
stuff
it'd probably be stuff they're not
interested in
i just talk about guns and stuff i just
noticed that sandra's name is uh sandra
and no zombies are just hungry people
that's true
yeah
i don't know where she got that one
i don't know what she got david june
boys only except for my mom some kids in
my neighborhood had that as their sign
growing up in tennessee yeah yeah you
should have that like a little treehouse
type of thing like no girls allowed and
then have and then have like a little um
like a little drawing of a girl with
like little smelly pig pen lines like
girls are stinky see that goes tom gonna
have a dating show i'm confused
he's going to give dating advice
oh my god
that would be super funny
oh my god
yeah you should do that you should give
dating advice
it'll just be it'll it'll be anything
yeah well yeah each show will have its
own topic kind of like this show is
gonna be probably well because okay so
the thing about this show i'm we're
gonna talk about reincarnation on here
yeah but paranormal show it's gonna be
good i kind of which will be fun because
it's like at least because the last show
we did was like a really depressing
topic yeah
uh it was unit 731. so this one will
just be kind of like fun and funny and
stuff like that but i also wanted to
kind of combine it with the sidetrack
show
just because we didn't do one on
wednesday
so
i mean i know we go off topic all the
time anyways
um but
i'm not gonna worry about it as much if
we go off topic this time because it's
not like
you know no no one got murdered or
anything like that so i don't feel bad
like going off on different tangents and
[ __ ] there's not gonna be wigs tonight
all wigs are at the other place all the
wigs are in the new house oh the new
studio
almost everything is at the new house
except for beds the beds yeah and
just my work [ __ ] yeah
because i can't because the
refrigerators oh in the refrigerator
gotta put it yeah got i got a
refrigerator i'm not going to leave here
i mean that place has a good one but i
run two i gotta have two we have to have
two then i gotta move two generators
gotta remove the emergency [ __ ] in
africa yeah and then um we have to get
another uh big old that big old wooden
bench
lawn that you know out there on the back
patio oh yeah yeah yeah but you know i
got i got three guys coming to help me i
rented three hands in a truck you rented
three people yeah you rented three men
for two hours
yeah yeah for two hours you know
and i i
i can get it all of it in one load
and uh i think i think four of us can
pick that that thing up it must be 400
300 pounds but yeah we can do it we can
do it we're pookie and beijing they're
still here they're still here we're
gonna take them uh at the last minute
they're
beijing seems well beijing's been
through a move she's been moves yeah she
knows what this is um once or twice so
she kind of like she sees what's going
on she's like all right i don't know
what's happening yeah she goes um pookie
is kind of like she's like what's yeah
what he took it why'd you take it yeah
where'd he go she's like running all
over my office going there used to be
stuff here yeah it's gone what's going
on yeah and it's like she's i don't know
she's scared but she is acting like a
lot more needy yeah like she's been
jumping up in the bed like a couple
times at night being like you guys still
here i think she's afraid we're gonna
leave we'll see that's what i was
worried about i thought that because um
all of the stuff is leaving the house i
thought she would be like oh my god our
mommy and daddy will leave me here too
or or
are they taking me out of the house
well we are taking her they we are
taking her out of the house she's gonna
like
she knows something's up she's like the
the stuff is leaving and it's not coming
back yeah somewhere
like when she sees it she's gonna love
it
i hope so yeah she's gonna love it i
hope so she's gonna have a lot more i
got i even got her i got her a new like
special litter box because i told her
the other day i was like i got you a new
bathroom
yeah so you know so we can put that
upstairs because like you know we just
have one story before so yeah dennis is
uh dennis is already in a new house he's
sitting there waiting yeah dennis and
h.h holmes are both in the sitting on
the floor in the office waiting for my
waiting for me to put them all on the
shelves
uh dj maniac said they gave you all a
month and you decided to do it in a
[ __ ] week
well you know he cut me down to two
weeks yeah well what ended up happening
was that
initially he was like yeah you can have
what did he say like a month or two
but then he was like well y'all i would
really rather y'all not move in until
you get the um electricity under your
name right so it's like well i don't
want to pay for two months of
electricity at like two houses right
yeah you know what i mean so basically
we have the power switched on over there
and we're like well you know maybe just
a week or two we can live with that like
having to pay for two houses electricity
so we were like okay well we got to do
this like
right away
so we're trying to like cram it all in
like i said so i don't really have to
we're trying to just get it all done you
know i had no idea we had so much [ __ ]
in this house until
we started having to put it on the
[ __ ]
put it on the [ __ ] trucks we've been
like running back and forth in the car
you know a couple times a day
i went over there this morning i'm
trying to finish the office is done
like uh i painted that
and uh everything that's gonna go in
there is in there
but you put the bookshelves together i
still i've got a desk today i have to
put that together tomorrow i have two
more desks that are coming tomorrow that
i have to put together
and then i'll just start putting
everything like put it all together and
um i was trying i was painting the
bathroom too i got most it has like a
little dressing room and then the
bathroom i got the dressing room painted
and most of the bathroom is painted i
just have to like finish it up that two
truckloads day where i rented that
u-haul and filled up that thing twice in
that day that [ __ ] me up man i had to
rest the next day after that
i had to [ __ ] take some steroids for
that day
well yeah you took a bunch that day yeah
i couldn't believe i was running it man
because you said
because i went to the house like i went
to the house in the morning and i was
like okay well i'm going to paint
because i want to at least get this room
finished and i want to like and i had to
like clean everything out of the
because we put everything in the room
that was going to be the gym yeah and
you were like yeah you need to get
everything out of there so i can set the
gym up so i had to get everything out of
there and that took forever but so i was
at the house by myself most of the day
and he's like okay well i'm gonna come
over with one u-haul and he's like he
you said you rented it for six hours
yeah i think you [ __ ] went got
another one you gave it like unloaded i
helped him like unload the truck and
then he left
and then like i'm painting away and then
the u-haul comes back like with another
huge load and he just like unloaded i
was like i thought you i couldn't let it
go how you had to take the truck back i
couldn't let it go i just looked at it
and says i'll do it again
i wasn't getting tired you know
but then like last night you were just
like then i woke up the next morning and
i was like oh why did i do that and you
guys i don't know if you can see i was
like i wonder can people see like i was
like look at i don't know if you can see
it or not i can't wait
i have my my whole arms and like stuff
like that are just covered with breezes
from moving stuff my legs are too i was
i was [ __ ] mighty mouse that day you
were i was [ __ ] i banged up some
tests and took anavar
yeah
he was just like oh yeah i was like on a
psycho [ __ ] uh 60 milligrams of
[ __ ] avar
running like a [ __ ] locomotive i was
[ __ ] strong that day yeah i couldn't
believe it
[ __ ] lifting everything
lifting [ __ ] by myself yeah carrying
[ __ ] upstairs on your shoulder carrying
[ __ ] big old [ __ ] air conditioner
window units and [ __ ] putting them up on
the top side
[Laughter]
up on the top shelf inside the garage
see we knew you were working out for
something
[Laughter]
and every time i'd stop i'd start to
[ __ ] fall asleep and i'd have to
[ __ ] oh
yeah
and that air conditioning could get me
because it was [ __ ] hot man it was
really hot it was really hot yesterday i
couldn't believe it yeah but you know
where's it's it's slowly going those
most of the most of this house is empty
i think all that's left is the beds
that other fridge yeah and
a couple couches
and just like a couple of little things
you know what i mean most of the shit's
gone out of here but there's just like a
couple little toys i have like 40
million bottles of shampoo and
conditioner and [ __ ] i gotta take over
there yeah
but yeah see grandpa's already can't
wait for the first [ __ ] day of the
tom ross show
what's going to be you know tame the
wild women and stuff a wild woman yeah
i don't know i'm probably gonna have
some kind of format you know what i mean
where i could just play off the play off
the crowd i'll probably do something
like read news and make [ __ ]
commentary and then there'll probably be
a topic
we'll see yeah and then maybe like a
backup topic we'll see we'll see how it
goes thank you tila
what do you say which goes toward much
needed massages from the move yeah we
probably will need the lick tina gonna
come give us a massage
she's gonna have a happy ending too
[Laughter]
you know tina had her own rub and tug
that's her [ __ ] job
just don't let her husband know she
doesn't
husband doesn't know where that money's
coming from
she got that [ __ ] in one of those
[ __ ] burned out strip malls
hidden in the back
near the insurance office insurance
claim office what's uh so what's it
called can you think of a good name
[Laughter]
oh my
god that's so funny
esther says love the t-shirts thank you
this one i totally forgot that i had
this shirt this is what happens when you
move you find stuff that you don't i
don't even know where where even was
this i just like found it i was like oh
my god this is like what is i got this
from the old satellite news old mystery
science theater shop uh because it's
kind of like a a reference to something
from one of the old shows
and it's like almost brand new i'm like
what the [ __ ] i bought it and then i was
just kind of like where did i i must
have stashed it somewhere and forgot i
had it
so i was like well [ __ ] i'm wearing that
but yeah that's the one we made so uh
[Music]
uh danny rolling ghostface says some
conspiracy theorist stuart swerdlow of
the montauk project says the moon is a
recycling center for the human souls
the moon yeah he's tripping
makes total sense okay i can i can we're
gonna do this when this topic here you
know i have some personal experience
with this [ __ ] and not not necessarily
reincarnating but uh i said some weird
[ __ ] to my dad when i was a kid but i
haven't i have a different explanation
for it i told my dad i remembered
something that had happened to me and
him
but it didn't happen to me and him it
happened to him and his dad
that's some weird see i feel like that's
really kind it's like i don't know i'll
tell that story and then i had a
near-death experience with a motorcycle
accident and i had a what's called a
an uh a [ __ ] spontaneous obe a
spontaneous out of body
uh experience uh
when i was laying in bed i was at fort
campbell kentucky in the barracks
and a dude named davis who was my
roommate at the time saw it happen
it was like poltergeist
it was weird
in both cases though of those two
it kind of exteriorized you know what it
felt like like
not my conscious became my consciousness
became non-localized i was just in an
area it was weird
it's just a little bitty tom particle or
you could do whatever you could spread
out over an area or look at things from
two different points of view at the same
time and
also you kind of had a co i kind of had
uh
um
an understanding of like [ __ ]
best way to describe is kind of like
higher and lower dimensions are
different dimensions
um and some of them kind of were like
heavenly realms that ended up being
kind of like
a god i guess you could say
yeah it was weird
weird i don't know why i made that noise
but um i'm a little loopy you guys
so
the reincarnation thing
i think it might be plausible
but
based on my on what i saw you wouldn't
be able to you wouldn't be retaining
much of your original personality you
wouldn't retain any of your
memories
you know what i mean your memories from
that prior life are gone
well i do kind of feel like even people
that believe in reincarnation um i think
the sort of overriding uh belief is
that
most of the time
uh you remember stuff from your past
life your purported past life before
you're five years old and then after
that you don't even really remember it
anymore yeah mo the weird thing i was
talking about remembering [ __ ] when was
when i was a kid
it's kind of like
once you have enough of your own
memories you don't have those memories
anymore
which i noticed that yeah but you know i
could probably
spill the beans now
it may have been in this case what what
some people kind of reported maybe like
inherited memories
like that i may have remembered
i told my dad when i was a little kid i
asked him i said do you remember that
time we were on that tractor
and the wheel with the wheel on the side
of the tractor went in the hole we fell
off
my dad was like no
that was you know
five
you know yeah he's like you don't
remember we fell off the tractor and you
laughed
and he's like no no and and uh
he didn't say anything to me at the time
but my mom told me later when i got
older that he said
he said to my mom he says that was some
weird [ __ ] because that didn't happen to
us that happened to me and my dad
when i was a little kid my dad i was
riding on a tractor with my dad
and uh
tractor tipped over and we fell off and
he laughed
we didn't get they didn't get hurt you
know they were they were going slow
and uh but for some reason i remembered
that
even though it didn't happen it didn't
happen to me no
but it could have been
a memory of something that i had
inherited
genetically
see now that's kind of an intriguing
possibility to me like inherited memory
well think about it animals are born
with animals and instead insects are
born with knowledge and
things that they couldn't know
they shouldn't know and they don't have
to learn it because they can do it like
right from so maybe they just inherit a
certain amount of memories from their
ancestors until they have their own
experiences and it replaces it and then
they pass it down
to the next generation yeah like the way
a computer would do it
you know what i mean the way a machine
would work yeah
you could open a door pump
what
she's like pushing at the door so maybe
it's okay you know maybe it's something
to do with that maybe it might be
genetic
that was one thing i could think of
that's a possibility and so in that way
it's not so much like your little
consciousness is like or your soul is
like floating around out there and going
be like oh i'm gonna go in that baby
right there and then like the kid's like
hey i remember my past life where i fell
off that tractor
i don't know i don't
i remember it yeah it didn't happen to
me
that's
i don't know it's really weird i don't
really
here's the thing it's like um i don't
have any kids but i grew up around a lot
of kids i have a lot of like younger
siblings and younger cousins and my
parents were in a daycare and blah blah
kids say
weird [ __ ] yeah all the time
and uh just random [ __ ] because of their
imagination and i don't think that
necessarily means that they're
remembering a past life i think
sometimes when they say something really
weird that coincidentally like um lines
up with something the parents remembered
about like say their parents or
something like that they'll be like oh
my god the kid must be like a
reincarnation of and then they'll start
asking questions and maybe leading them
in a certain direction i don't really
know i'm not
you know i'm not saying that i don't
necessarily believe it well i don't know
i don't think i necessarily believe in
it but
like you said it might be interesting to
you know to look maybe into the
possibility of like cell memory or you
know some kind of ancestral memory or
something like that you know what i'm
saying okay did you uh thank everybody
for christmas
not yet christmas earning christmas
birthday presents and and bert you know
some of his birthday money it was yes so
yeah esther was in here before and i
don't think i don't remember if she was
here the other day like when i um
because i was wearing the necklace that
she sent me and i said thank you for
that today i'm wearing the earrings that
she sent me for my birthday cool and
these are super odd i love the color of
these oh they're so pretty
uh so thank you very much for that
esther if you weren't here like because
i because like i said i wore that i was
wearing the necklace before
um also i wanted to thank dermot
who i'm not sure if he's here today but
uh he sent me some birthday money over
paypal so thank you very much for that
also i don't know if tammy is here but
thank you tammy for sending me she also
sent me some money and she sent me this
hilarious card look at this card
look it's a little naked hot dog with
lil
that says nude beach on it look at the
butt crack the butt crack is killing me
and inside it says of course
party your buns off
so
so thank you very much tammy yeah there
she is there she is
so uh yeah so thank you very much
everybody for my birthday presents i
don't know if uh oh thank you zack i
like to believe in the idea of
reincarnation and ghost because there's
too many things in the world that
science doesn't have satisfying answers
for yet yeah i'd agree with that um
i don't know i don't know if i believe
in ghosts in the sense of
hey i'm gonna like i'm hanging around as
a spirit to like tell you where i buried
my treasure type of [ __ ]
um if i do if i did believe in ghosts it
would be more of like a you know just a
thing like replaying like a tape that's
not really all that conscious
like a recorded hologram like a recorded
hologram like i might go that far but i
don't know if i'd go as far as like a
like an apparition that's actually like
sentient you know what i'm saying
uh
well
going out of body astral projection and
stuff
i would think that's it's possible that
something like that could happen because
i was aware that there were
beings
that had not i guess you could say gone
to heaven but they're just living in
these different dimensions some of them
higher and some of them lower
although
most of them don't seem to be
interacting on this
plane that sounds tacky as [ __ ] you know
what i mean i don't know what else to
describe
they're not really interacting man
yeah they're not really they're not
really doing much here it's kind of like
this isn't their natural element
although they could probably see it but
they probably get bored and gravitate
more
closer to where they belong
they're not
from what i saw they're not um
they're not
living creatures or people like we are
that you know that have instincts and
drives they're more like a collection of
memories and willpower
you know what i mean yeah they're not uh
they don't have daily needs they're not
going to work you know what i mean
they're not they don't they're not
paying bills
but they're not worried about how much
gas is going to take
[Laughter]
and their sense of time is going to be
very
warped
um so
something like a ghost or a distant you
know a disembodied person might interact
with our dementia for a while but i
think that they because of the way time
flows when you're in that state
you'd lose uh
you'd lose concentration you'd stop
paying attention pretty quickly from our
point of view yeah yeah i mean
time is not flowing the same way for
them
well and it might be the case that you
know it when you're on earth or you know
this is all hypothetical but when you're
on earth in this in this body or
whatever everything seems super
important but like you said when you
went out of body
everything it was just kind of like meh
yeah exactly like it wasn't really that
big it's not that interesting yeah
and uh
where they are is more interesting to
them they're more built for that
you know what i mean they're not they're
not physical they're pure
pure kind of uh i don't want to even say
energy yes they are they're like quantum
particles
a bunch of quantum particles
that has a consciousness but
the consciousness might not it's not
going to be like ours you know what i
mean like they don't have instinct and
[ __ ] like that you know because there
isn't it's not attached to a
a human brain that has needs it's it's
uh
it's weird you know
if anybody's here pancakes and booze
yeah it's almost kind of like they're
almost kind of like in a dream like
state it'd be a good way to put it that
sounds nice they're like they're more
like that i think i would like that
although my dreams are super [ __ ]
weird yeah so
well for them it's kind of like the
internet
they're experiencing whatever they're
thinking about or what they want to
experience yeah that'd be kind of neat i
like that idea yeah but you can just
kind of like float around they're
floating around and they're [ __ ]
thinking things and you can go over here
universal [ __ ] about this they're kind
of like in the matrix yeah the universe
is interacting with them it's becoming
what they want it to be it's kind of and
then it changes and then they'll move on
grant there's hammer said are you going
to miss the ghost in your house well no
because
he's coming with us yeah
i wonder i wonder why your poltergeist
decided to steal your motorcycle key
for several days and then give it back
to pookie because i i had worried about
it remember
yeah
yeah i said i'm gonna have to replace
these i'm gonna have to get a copy of
these keys in case i lose it lose one of
them and it vanished
so your worries were realized yeah you
must have really been worrying about it
and then it's like yeah well your
poltergeist was like no you can't show
you what it's like you can't focus on
something that you come across in
passing it's a thought just in passing
they'd be like ah yeah i don't worry
about it but then it comes back to get
you and then it comes back to get you
yeah he surprises you if you worried
about it too much then it wouldn't do it
because you paid too much attention to
it
oh okay yeah i mean it's just random
like that kind of random how funny they
cannot try if you try and stops it it's
more like the the lack of trying there's
no way to describe it it's kind of like
thinking about it in a different
direction
i just think it's so funny that when the
key came back it came back literally
between pookie's paws yeah well no i
just because she had it
yeah but there's nowhere she could have
gotten it no she didn't i just got done
petting her pet her like that and looked
and looked down and then she rolled over
and she's like she's kind of yeah and
then she was like chewing on it she was
and i was like whoa
where did you get that hair stood up
it's like where yeah she had it
remember
it framed her
remember because i said maybe pookie
took it well that's what we were
thinking because we couldn't find it in
the regular places so i was like well
maybe pookie wandered out i didn't think
she would have taken it anywhere that we
couldn't find it
because she doesn't have like it she
only has like a couple little stash
places and they're not super secret you
know what i mean she didn't have the
dexterity to get it
she found her back i was rubbing her
stomach she was fighting with me and
then i looked down and she had it
i don't you know there's no place she
could have gotten it yeah that's like
it's like a drop that i know when she
grabbed it was she probably like oh boy
like i threw it to her you know yeah
because she likes to fetch you know yeah
dermot says i've experienced sleep
paralysis a few times which was
terrifying i think it's more sleep
disturbance rather than anything demonic
but i keep an open mind i have had one
episode of sleep paralysis i've had it
um
it happened when uh before we moved in
together i lived in an apartment over on
in winter park and i lived by myself and
i woke up in the middle of the night my
like my sleep schedule was kind of wonky
because i worked the night shift and i
and i worked like really far away like i
lived like uh lived like an hour away
from work
so i woke up in the middle of the night
and i
swore that i saw a dude with a baseball
bat standing in my bedroom door the
weird thing about it though was that
i wasn't
scared like i was but not as scared as
you would be so maybe even like from the
uh from the first time that i saw it i
knew that maybe it wasn't really there
because you think if i if i woke up and
really saw that i would like [ __ ]
[ __ ] a brick sleep paralysis and um
astral projection or out-of-body
experiences there's a link there
because i had that
obe
and i know what that feels like
and then um
a couple years after that
i woke up
from asleep dead sleep
and it was i was in the middle of sleep
and i was paralyzed in that sleep
paralysis
and i didn't really i didn't panic i
knew what it was
but it felt so good i realized that hey
i could i could leave my body if i
wanted to right now
i felt like i could actually project as
a word is a word some people would use
for it so i could leave right now and as
i said as i thought that
i saw myself from above just for a
second and i went whoa i did it and then
i clicked back
so it's
related yeah you think all of that stuff
would be if you you know if all that
stuff is real it's gotta be like all
related it's all related in some way
because it has to do with like your yeah
i recognize or whatever
i was i was paralyzed but i was awake
but i could certain parts of my brain
were still asleep that's why i couldn't
move kind of like waking up with us
with your foot asleep or something you
couldn't move it but your whole body you
can't move it's paralyzed
certain parts like the conscious part of
your brain's working but the rest of the
rest of you your brain that runs the
body isn't
and it felt like an obe
and i said i could leave
and that's what and then i was looking
down at myself
in bed
and then when i did it and then the
surprise [ __ ]
stopped it i clicked back and boom i was
back and
back looking through normal eyes and i
felt super exhausted and went back to
sleep instantly lost
instantly lost consciousness
from it
so
doing it somehow
wears you out
that's it was like that when i
had that obe in the army when they were
shaking me and i came back yeah and i
opened my eyes i said dude why'd you do
that and i couldn't stay awake
yeah
it's weird
that is pretty weird yeah well i guess
certain parts of your brain are trying
to shut off yeah when this is happening
it's some kind of confusion between
centers of your brain which allows
your consciousness to slip out of there
you're giving up the ghost
and it's not effort it's like the lack
of effort it's kind of like
kind of feels like
allowing yourself to die
what it kind of feels like yeah yeah
weird a couple people are brought up uh
brought up exploding head syndrome as
well which uh i think that's yeah that's
uh
fairly common i've heard about that i've
never had that myself and like i said
i've only had one sleep paralysis thing
i hope i never have it because it sounds
awful and the one time i had it was
really weird even though i'm pretty sure
i mean i was scared but it wasn't
i think i immediately like twigged on to
the fact that it wasn't real so it
wasn't but i couldn't move i was just
standing there looking at this dude that
was standing there with the bat
and then i'm sitting there going is that
guy really there for some reason for
some reason sandra can't get her stream
running
i don't know is it everybody is it okay
for everybody else yeah my my little my
little square is still green
camp guy said i knew a gal that had to
go to the doctor for sedatives after she
saw the exorcist during the original run
she was having demonic hallucinations
yeah probably well you know if if you're
kind of sensitive to that kind of stuff
i guess that would happen
and i feel like in 1973 when that movie
came out uh no one had really seen
anything
like that before so
people did have kind of like an extreme
reaction to it
but um
i don't know it's weird because i was
kind of reading a bunch of stuff about
reincarnation and this probably this
thought never really occurred to me
before
but
um you know obviously reincarnation much
more common in eastern religions you
know hinduism buddhism what not um and
to them it's like not that big a deal
they just kind of take it for granted
the only reason that it's rarer in
western like in sort of judeo-christian
type of um
you know belief systems
is that
i mean the whole thing about the
judeo-christian thing is just you live
this one life and it's not that
important you're just trying to like do
[ __ ] and then you have like an eternal
afterlife
whereas
because you know they see time more like
linear where in a way like eastern
religions kind of see things
more cyclical which is actually kind of
close to the truth and you would think
that more the more western religions
would be like that because
i mean obviously you can see cycles you
can see cycles of seasons and you know
stuff like that so
it seems like a very natural thing for
humans to
extrapolate
um so it's interesting to me that the
western religions didn't really catch on
to that although the ancient greeks kind
of like some of the ancient greeks
believed in some of that stuff right
like plato did and everything like that
i don't think it was exactly the same
but we have to accept that
um
everything we know
of
ancient greco-roman history anything
that's pre-christian
anything we know about
the pre-christian history of the west
was we are allowed to know that because
the church erased everything it didn't
like pretty much yeah it's it's amazing
that everything survived from back then
yeah to be honest right yeah once
once that once the catholic church took
over eastern europe it just over
centuries it just purged out
anything having to do with any other
religions that were around before it
and it had a lot to do with the fact
that
christianity copied a lot from those
religions so they didn't want yeah they
called it diabolical syncretism i think
is what one of them were they were
saying that the dev the the churches
and the church's ancient explanation was
is that the devil went back in time and
created all these religions that were
like christianity to sow the seeds of
doubt in christianity that the devil
knew was coming
i think the thing is yeah
yeah i'm sure the devil has better
things to do so
they dig up these old you know
roman statues and they looked a lot like
christian statues or they'd find these
old roman books and in the books you
know some of the characters are saying
things that jesus said and they're going
the devil did that
you know
burn that book that's
the devil yeah the devil did that he's
always getting into everything yeah he's
back in the past
back in the past predicting what jesus
was going to say
yeah
he went back to the past and his [ __ ]
delorean
called what was it called somebody that
some in the comment section might might
know i think it's called diabolical
syncretism
maybe although it's not quite
that's not quite the same thing
but the church the old catholic church
believed in it a lot so they just
[ __ ] destroyed anything and and
they were just hiding the fact that
christianity was kind of a
a hodgepodge of a lot of european roman
stuff that was around before yeah they
totally like stole stuff from like total
dynasty they didn't even give a [ __ ]
about copyright or anything back then
it's just like oh i like that story
let's go it's kind of like it's kind of
like nowadays if you took like all the
best scenes from your favorite marvel
movies and just put them all together
into a book and try to publish it
instead it was all superman and said
i said it was all superman yeah and then
when somebody called you on it you would
be like no because like uh stan lee went
back in time and did i don't know they
were like
yeah they wouldn't even get a [ __ ]
between dc and marvel
still all superman we're just kind of
like yeah
well
when you when you look at the new
testament the new testament is a reboot
of the old testament
jesus's birth narrative is very similar
to moses it is yeah and uh they're
saying he's the second coming of moses
really
he's the new law giver
and a lot of [ __ ] happens in there and
then he says a lot of stuff that
kind of sounds like something that that
uh oh what's his name
socrates would say
and um
there's a lot of stuff that happens in
there it looks like
you know the last supper scene looks
like uh the last supper from
uh what was that that other religion
that they had at that time
um
mithraism yeah
the myth rape let
the mythic temples all have these damn
12 people eating and eating a meal
there's your 12 disciples it's funny how
there's 12 of them and there's also 12
sides of the zodiac there's a lot of 12
over and over again
and you know
they're stealing stuff what was that
series that we watched i don't know if
it's on youtube or not we watched it
like a couple years ago and the guy was
like it was like a really long like
lecture or presentation or something and
he was making a pretty compelling
argument about
a lot of the stuff in the bible being
astrological being like based on like
zodiac signs yeah but it's also reboots
of roman stuff that too
because you have
a lot of parallels between jesus and
hercules they're both the son of god
basically both born of mortal women
um
you have
you have
zeus
you know
he's up on mount olympus he can't keep
it in his pants swinging his dick around
he's got all these children up there too
they're like the angels and they're all
having sex with mortal women and the
giants and demigods are being born by
them you know the nephilim
and it's it's
the romans would just call them damn
demigods
you know perseus and [ __ ]
so
as time went on in the in the you know
in in the uh we call it
in the abrahamic pantheon all the angels
got
dem see all the sons of god which there
said it's the sons of god in genesis the
sons of god all got all got demoted
into angels
and then they all got in chained because
they were knocking up all the damn women
bringing forth [ __ ] nephilim and [ __ ]
they were just such [ __ ] they just yeah
so it's the same it's the same universe
as the greco-roman
gods they're just using different names
for them
different stories yeah but that's what
it is
oh yeah i totally agree yeah
but you know the church didn't want you
knowing that back in the middle ages
they're like no this is a completely
original and true story that we're
telling you right now
there's just a continuation of what they
were doing before just rebooted all this
stuff about you know jesus drinking the
wine and all this communion stuff that's
straight out of [ __ ] the cult of
dionysus
yeah or bacchus
that might be the same god
wine drinking gods
the party god yeah
everyone's favorite
but uh yeah well it's interesting that
um uh tammy said too bad a person
couldn't remember from all their past
lives and learn from them that's to me
seems like that would be cheating well
but the thing about it is that if
reincarnation is real and if your whole
entire goal is let's say to achieve
enlightenment so you don't have to do it
anymore
then you forgetting everything from your
past life seems a little bit um
pointless you know no that's not what
the buddhists say
they say you has to reset that way you
have a fresh perspective you have to
play different roles
in in in life to exp to become well
faceted
not only do you have to be the victim
you have to be the [ __ ] perpetrator
you know what i mean not only do you
have to suffer you have to be the one
that causes the suffering you have to be
good and bad you have to so you can
understand
you have to know all perspectives so you
would lose all those perspectives if you
if you gained the amount if you had
memory of all the other stuff that you
had done
because basically what in that system
what they're talking about is that
you're in a theater watching a bunch of
different movies
each movie resets
yeah you know what i mean it's not the
same movie
it's not a series of movies
you're not [ __ ] seeing the exorcist
and then you see star wars and star wars
in the exorcist of the same universe
you
know so yeah i get it yeah so it's and
you're not you're supposed to kind of
like forget about that movie you saw
that movie this is the new movie yeah
we're in this movie now yes
yeah and according to according to a lot
a lot of that buddhist uh philosophy
you've chosen to see this movie that you
see it
because it's one you haven't seen
yeah that's interesting because i feel
like well buddhism came around a little
bit later because i feel like the the
main um proponents i guess of
reincarnation were hindus which was has
been around a lot longer in fact i
believe hinduism is the what the oldest
uh religion that's still practiced i
thought buddhism was no uh buddhism is
actually
uh newer
there are some there are some things
that jesus say in in some of the in in
some of those gospels that sound a lot
like stuff that siddhartha gautama the
first buddha would have said
yeah there's a lot of buddhas people
think there's only one buddha no there's
a [ __ ] ton of buddhists yeah it's not a
name it's a title it's a title it's just
like enlightened one yeah and
prince gotum was the first one i had to
read siddhartha yes
he was the first one yeah and they show
him [ __ ] this fat [ __ ] from
smiling and they shot him fat because he
starved himself to death
all right
but he was fat in wisdom
not in cupcakes
well he got so old you know people
his people were taking care of him you
know he had
rich families you know he they hired him
as a wise man
and he said
[ __ ] this [ __ ]
i don't have a job i don't do anything
[Laughter]
all i do is take
they give me food and it's somebody
else's food
and everything i i'm wearing clothes and
this clothes could be used for somebody
else you know and i'm eating food that
other people could eat i'm too old you
know i've been i've just been taking
take and taken from this life
so i'm gonna i'm gonna stop taking you
know i'm gonna stop eating and they said
but but master you'll die and he goes oh
don't you question me [ __ ]
he's paraphrasing better
question me [ __ ]
you know don't tell me what to do i'm a
man
so you stop you're not the boss of me
yeah you're not the boss of me so he
would he was like 80. so you know
whatever
he stopped eating and he starved to
death and they said please master eat
food you're dying and he goes ah shut
the [ __ ] up y'all just being jealous
because you're trying to be you're
worried about yourself because you know
that when i'm gone you all are suffer
suffer without me
you're doing it you're just well kind of
drama queen yeah yeah
y'all just you'll miss me when i'm gone
yeah y'all just asking me to stay for
your own selfish [ __ ] reasons
let me go god damn it let me go
so he you know stop being selfish
stop being selfish
so so he died he died a skinny ass old
man so then they started making statues
of a fat with a big old [ __ ] smile on
his face [ __ ] you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you
well was he not was he not the one that
came up with the whole
uh
moderation in everything type stuff
because
yeah that's what i mean it's just kind
of like you can't like be completely um
a bunch of different interpretations you
know yeah it's kind of where you know
the uh the jedi the
co you know it's where the word uh
what's his name joseph campbell
helped
help jo uh uh [ __ ] george lucas come
up with the ideas from star wars you
know in the jedi it's kind of based
on on buddhist thought you know yeah and
um
siddhartha was born as a damn
really rich kid yeah in a damn castle
his dad was a [ __ ]
badass warlord
and he had everything that his heart
could desire and he's looking out over
the castle walls you see all these poor
people and he's like man why is it i
have all this [ __ ] all right and those
people have nothing
and they go they got nothing and they're
unhappy because i got everything and i'm
unhappy i don't [ __ ] like the palace
and he goes what's life about
so you know pleasure gives me no [ __ ]
pleasure [ __ ] this [ __ ] i'm i'm i'm out
of here so he left and just lived out in
the wild with a bunch of [ __ ] monks
who would just do stupid [ __ ] like chew
on rocks
anything that would cause them suffering
it would rain and they'd stand out in
the rain you know what i mean and let
and and then they'd [ __ ] put rocks in
their shoes they'd make everything
[ __ ] uncomfortable they wouldn't eat
good food they'd mix rotten food in with
good food to destroy all [ __ ]
pleasure
he didn't learn anything that either
he's like man he's like oh these people
are idiots
why would you do that
[Laughter]
so he started to [ __ ] go upon the
middle path
and in his [ __ ] middle path he's like
you have to be detached from [ __ ] okay
stop being so wrapped up in this crap
he comes up
i'm going to give you my paraphrase
he says everything you doubt tom
everything you have and everything you
think is yours is not yours it actually
belongs to the world you just have it
temporarily if i give you something good
like this pretty ass vase you're gonna
go man this vase is so [ __ ] pretty
so you felt happy when you had it but
then when it [ __ ] hit the ground and
shattered now now you're all [ __ ] up
about it oh my vase see had you not
given a [ __ ] it wouldn't have mattered
you got to keep your [ __ ] desires on
on on you cannot get attached to things
so he came up
with the things they were called the the
the noble truths or the golden truths
all right
he says only things are true
are things that are always true and will
always be true and the first thing that
is always true is that life is [ __ ]
up two it's [ __ ] up
all right
all right one is [ __ ] up two is [ __ ]
up
because
you are desiring things
that
eventually disappoint you
okay yeah all right everything you want
eventually you're going to be just
you're going to be disappointed with all
right
three
if you stop desiring these things
you'll never be disappointed
[Laughter]
i kind of can't i kind of came to that
on my own yeah
[Laughter]
four the only way to stop desiring
things is to reach a state called
nirvana
it's a state of enlightened indifference
it means you know but you don't give a
[ __ ] yeah i know i don't give a [ __ ]
that's kind of like that
i know that this is nice but i'm not
attached to it it's okay stuff's
temporary it comes and goes do not be
attached to people ideas or material
objects they're transitory they come and
go including you you are just coming and
going none of this is yours not even you
belong to you
all this [ __ ] belongs to the universe to
the force god damn it the force
you become one with a force
man the universe can have my father yes
seriously and maybe
[Laughter]
you want it back you can have it there
are tails going way back that some
people have come back from the force and
that's what a ghost is
like obi-wan like obi-wan
they learned how to come back from the
force well yeah well and this is another
thing that's kind of funny to me too is
that i feel like
people that um tend to believe in
reincarnation in the west
um
it's almost you can they kind of see it
like it's a positive thing but in
eastern religions it's not really seen
as a positive thing
it's not neces reincarnation yeah no no
it's kind of like um yeah your whole
goal is to like not go through all that
[ __ ] again yeah we have to understand
some
existence itself is wrong
in the buddhist thought and i'm gonna
explain this [ __ ]
tom explains it all let me explain some
[ __ ] i'm gonna get i'm gonna break down
some ancient wisdom
okay he's laying down
this is the same wisdom that
arthur scopenhauer and friedrich
nietzsche ended up discovering that they
reinterpreted buddhism
everything
imposes on other things
you cannot exist without imposing on
other things
grass
grows and it takes nutrients from the
ground and [ __ ] over other grass by
taking that that nutrient they even
fight each other over the [ __ ]
kilograms oh yeah
and then a rabbit comes and eats them
eats them up and then a wolf comes and
eats that rabbit
and then a man comes and eats that wolf
the rabbit and the grass
and then every
even inanimate objects
[ __ ] over other inanimate objects
just by occupying space that another
object could occupy
you cannot exist on this planet without
imposing on other things and on other
people
everything you have
somebody else could be making greater
use of the [ __ ] clothes that you have
on your back
that you just take it for granted if
somebody else had them they would be
wouldn't be starving they wouldn't be
freezing to death right now the food
that you're you're eating and neglecting
to eat somebody else could be using that
right now
just you walking around breathing okay
you're breathing air that other people
could be breathing somebody's down and
[ __ ] been buried alive and you know
woke up in the damn coffin that give me
just another breath of air they could
use that air motherboard don't be so
selfish all right even these [ __ ]
businessmen are trying to do this [ __ ]
they try to game everything about
[ __ ] taxes and credits and carbon
credits and [ __ ] everything imposes and
they're gonna impose on you
the only way and when you impose
you're wrong
it's wrong it's wrong to impose
the only way to not impose and to be
right is to not exist
so you all need to go ahead and do what
you need to do get the [ __ ] out of here
all right that's the that's the thinking
all right
it's it's extreme
but the world is an extreme place and
philosophy is always kind of extreme a
certain way
but that's an extreme way of looking at
it
there's a lot of different kinds of
buddhist interpretation that's like yeah
that's true but that you know but you
know [ __ ] it there's nothing you can do
about it that's the state of things you
know what i mean that's kind of the way
i feel about it it's like yeah that's
you know that that's true as far as it
goes but it's like what the hell am i
supposed to do about it i don't want to
necessarily kill myself so right well
that's what you can tell
that's who you can tell you know is a
fake and who's the real thing so you
know sid hartha was the real thing he's
like [ __ ] it i'm out of here i don't
even eat
he died
he said if you're going to die because
yeah but i'm going to go to another
dimension man i'm [ __ ] i'm graduating
from this [ __ ] i'm sick of [ __ ]
imposing
okay it's wrong
[Laughter]
so you got these [ __ ]
it's just like these college students
running around trying to shut down the
damn oil industry well they don't have a
car when they have a car they're going
to want to put gasoline in it or
something
and then you know oh we and then if you
stop if you take away all gasoline then
the trucks stop running and when the
truck stops when everybody starts
starving to death because
trucks deliver all the damn food
so there's no way out of it if you
really believe that you're imposing kill
yourself
just just kill yourself
you know that hypothetically
that's what that's basically what
well friedrich nietzsche came up he read
all this and he goes man only a loser
would would [ __ ] believe this [ __ ]
friedrich nietzsche says man this is the
philosophy of a [ __ ] loser a beta
beta beta male
this it is true that life is imposing
yeah yeah it is true all right that the
things are about
natural selection and everything and if
that's true then that means you really
have nothing to lose
and if you have nothing to lose then you
better it's better to just go down
fighting for what you want and to try to
get something out of life this is what
you talk about in star wars about going
to the dark side of going yeah yeah life
is about you know yeah [ __ ] this though
okay that means there's nothing to lose
i'm going for the [ __ ] gusto give me
your [ __ ]
that's another way you can do it
whatever you have actually is better
served if it was in my hands
give me everything you have you don't
deserve to have it that's another way of
looking at it
well i kind of think that whenever
somebody's doing something i don't like
i'd be like stop taking everyone's air
yeah
there would be more oxygen for the rest
of us if you weren't here yeah but vader
would just [ __ ] kill you and then say
your death is inconsequential
yeah
which where i didn't even get off on
killing you killing you didn't matter
it's like squashing them you were
nothing
but yeah so
so yeah so but like we were saying
reincarnation actually in eastern
religions is seen as
is kind of seen as a bad thing right
because yeah because you have to go back
because you have to keep going back that
means you didn't like right you didn't
win the prize this time around you gotta
you [ __ ] up something up you gotta
start over
now in
buddhism i told you about the noble
truths there's also something called the
wheel of suffering all right
look you can only escape the wheel of
suffering if you know the noble truths
the wheel of suffering is this
desire you see something you want okay
it's desire
fulfillment
regret
and then another desire so in other
words your
your life is nothing but wanting things
and then
being kind of like sick getting sick of
that
or being satisfied and then kind of
feeling bad about it like oh man i
[ __ ] spent all my money on that
goddamn car that car really went all
that [ __ ]
you know what
i want that other car
so
we're all kind of in this cycle of
wanting things
getting sick of them
and then
feeling bad about getting sick of it and
then replacing it with another desire
that we want that's called the wheel of
suffering because
life is like that you're hungry you
digest it you [ __ ] it out then you get
hungry again
that's it's all that same cycle okay and
the only way to escape it is by reaching
nirvana understanding an
enlightened indifference not worrying
about it not caring
or
a nichian would say no what you do is
you weaponize that
okay get what you want out of life
for your own amusement really
or for your own
empowerment that's another way to look
at it
although there's a lot of different
writers a lot of philosophers have
approached this in different
from different angles and they
even buddhists didn't agree all the the
buddhas themselves always had a slightly
different interpretation and taught a
different lesson
yeah i always thought it was so much i
mean and like i said i know buddhism is
like a [ __ ] giant religion it has
like factions just like every other
religion but i always thought it wasn't
so much not caring about stuff as just
kind of like rolling with it
sort of thing yeah in general but some
of them would said no
some of them were extremists and didn't
care
like there were tales of where
some warlord wanted some buddhist to do
something like [ __ ] no i ain't doing it
i'm not gonna do it so they start
cutting them apart
joint by joint starting with the toes
and the fingertips every joint the
person was cut apart and the whole time
the guy didn't even show a single bit of
pain because he didn't give a [ __ ] he
was hardcore hardcore
he just you know or they would be
singing and happy and [ __ ] totally uh
totally had reached total nirvana where
they didn't even care about their own
lives or their own physical pain or
anything they're like [ __ ] i don't
care yeah
cut me to pieces out of here
that's it i mean you know that's like a
good idea that's a pretty strong belief
that instead of instead of yielding or
giving in to something that some person
wanted
or um
stories of like a buddha sees some
people being [ __ ] murdered and does
nothing
at all there's like well it doesn't
matter
they would have died anyway
that kind of that kind of thing although
in a lot of ways there's i feel like
there's really a dark side to that
because it just makes you completely
passive yeah to be honest well that's
what nietzsche said this is kind of the
the the fl
and it gives you an excuse for just
sitting around being like not doing
anything yeah yeah
well
it enlightened and enlightened
detachment
might mean
you know that this shit's [ __ ] up you
know everything about it and and you're
you don't care anymore
which that's kind of
it's kind of a defeatist attitude in a
way that's well that's kind of how i see
it to me it just seemed like i was i
don't know i i just don't i wouldn't
want to live my life and yoda would say
some [ __ ] along the lines well you're
gonna just throw yourself into a
conflict that you can get yourself
killed it'd be additional death on top
of that that might be he might say
something like that like you can't help
those people
their their their destiny is already
decided because who they are in this war
that's happening so there's a bunch of
different ways you can you could you
could tackle it
you know what i mean yeah like for
instance you're
you're in poland and you see a damn
german death camp you know what i mean
and they're processing those people you
go out there and try to stop it they'll
kill you
they'll kill you yeah so stopping it you
trying to stop it would be a waste of
your time a waste of your life
it'd kill you
but if you could find a better way
other people would try
people in charge didn't want to do it
but they'd kill you if you didn't
that regime didn't take no for an answer
that's true okay
so
and
buddhism in these philosophies kind of
came from totalitarian societies anyway
a bunch of warlords and [ __ ]
so
and they were buddhist monks fighting
the samurai i remember we saw that thing
yeah that's right and some of them some
of them were
certain interpretations of buddhism was
we have to stop this evil
you know and if you're
so they would do they would do that too
it all just depended on what
what your local philosopher thought
yeah because like i said it's not like i
mean when people say you know buddhism
it's not just one it's yeah it's not
just one you know it's more like a
philosophy monolithic belief system it's
a bunch of different
divisions and it's more like a
philosophy it didn't really have
commandments
like a mo like a abrahamic religion head
where you have to do this and that if
you see this it was up to you to decide
what you what should be done
or not done
well i was going to say what probably
one of the most extreme uh versions of
that would be the it's uh the giants
right
and they actually um
they are so dead set on
well they so believe in reincarnation
and they believe that humans can be
reincarnated as anything like animals
insects plants whatever so it's like
they try really really hard like not to
like they i i remember reading this when
i was a kid they have they carry brooms
everywhere so they can sweep
like insects and stuff like out of their
path and stuff so they don't step on
them and obviously they don't like you
know eat meat or
anything like that but the thing about
it though is if if you believe that
people can be reincarnated as plants
then you can't really eat plants either
so you're just gonna have to like be a
breatharian i guess
i mean like i said it just
i don't know it to me it just seems like
any any kind of extreme like that
i i just don't see the point of it i
don't see the point of it
i i just kind of feel like you just
should not worry about it over much
try not to impose on anybody too much
but you can't like not impose because
like you said you existing is an
imposition
so
you know just try not to be a dick
that's all that's that's my philosophy
you know what i'm saying
it's like i don't have this big extreme
like let me get another drink and you
know like i said i think even like some
of the ancient greeks
well my shit's almost empty so just
i can't drink all that one time you
can't slam it
well i mean i can but i probably
shouldn't
that's close enough
it's close enough but i think even some
of the ancient greeks that believed in
reincarnation were vegetarians for that
very reason
i don't know if they were so extreme
that they actually thought that people
could be reincarnated as plants
how weird would that be
to be reincarnated as a [ __ ] tree or
something like that
i'm gonna i'm gonna come back as a venus
fly trap that's what i'm gonna come back
as
but yeah so i don't i don't know it's so
basically
what i was going to say too was that not
only was there like some ancient greek
ancient greeks like plato and stuff like
that that sort of
purported something something similar to
reincarnation but there were also some
like other
mystery religions too
um
that sort of had
that kind of like veneer to them
so
i mean
you had the one that was like what was
it called orphism
and uh that was like a little bit later
i think that was like 6th century bc
and
this was the same kind of thing like
your soul like your consciousness
survived your death and could be like
placed in another thing like another
person or an animal it could be an
animal too
um
and that they basically had the same
thing it was like kind of like a
negative
view in the in the sense that your soul
was like trapped by your body and when
you died it kind of released you but
then it had to go into another one so it
was like you know in prison and uh but
it was like trying to get
back to which i was reading about this
and i was like you know
uh what this sounds like too it sounds
kind of like scientology
because and i think that uh l ron
hubbard like read some [ __ ] about uh
reincarnation
because yeah because his the whole thing
about like body thetans and all that
like they're in your body and they're
trying to like
get back out again you're trying to get
them out that's kind of similar to what
some eastern religions say about
reincarnation
now i think some of the um
some of the factions over there actually
think that karma is like a physical
thing like there's karma particles
which like i said it's kind of like body
thetans
so i kind of feel like that's probably
where l ron hubbard got the idea from
probably
[Laughter]
what's that it's like there's just these
little like particles of
of karma juice like around laying around
in your body and you had to kind of like
that's just really really funny to me
um yeah so
where was i okay
somebody said it's funny that this
creator scientology is literally
a science fiction writer no it's not
it's not crazy at all
when you think about it
because
religions are kind of like science
fiction
so now it makes a lot of sense
that he he did that yeah
what's funny is that people believed it
that's that's the funny thing about it
yeah that's what i find funnier i don't
find it i don't find it particularly
crazy when somebody like invents a story
like that it's always just kind of like
the fact of something the fact that so
many people took it seriously that like
yeah
but yeah elrond hubbard actually said
was when he was talking about body
themes i found this like well hi pokey
look at her peeking
what you doing
[Laughter]
tila says can you imagine using karmic
fluid and injecting it into someone as a
weapon here's like some bad karma i got
saved up and it's like injected in
somebody's butt like with one of those
umbrellas like the spies used to use
well you know what l ron hubbard was
doing was a basically kind of like a
tried and true way of making money he he
he made that religion
but really it didn't really matter what
the religion said okay
it was basically the same grift that
that uh aleister crowley used it was the
make a [ __ ] a wizard grifft
that's how you drift all right i will
make you a wizard
you pay me a certain amount of money you
go through this course
and then
i'm gonna have nine of them isn't it
nine or eight
i thought nine never came but that was
like they well they made [ __ ] up like
after he died okay
they could start with eight yeah
so there were eight levels
and each course was progressively more
more and more expensive like half a
million dollars started to get
and they're doing this because they
believe
they'll be made into a wizard basically
that they'll have power
mental powers the power to stop time and
go back in time and fix a problem and go
for just
telekinesis uh all kinds of stupid [ __ ]
they're making a [ __ ] wizard or
making a [ __ ] a jedi
but i just wouldn't want to be a jedi
come on you can have all that like cool
powers and stuff
i mean you know i'm not dumb enough to
like pay half a million dollars to
somebody that says they make me a jedi
of course it doesn't work
and people who are ot8s who've left that
religion says no they can't do anything
any of the things that they were
promised that they could that they would
be able to do they didn't get any jedi
abilities but it kind of cracks me up
like because we were watching like leah
remini's show and stuff and then so they
would have like all these highlight
ranking people that had gone like to ota
and whatever was beyond that and then
they would they would interview with
them and like the interviewer would kind
of jokingly ask them it's like oh so
you'd have like magic powers and you can
like you know read people's minds and
stuff and they're just like
no we were promised that we'd be able to
do it i'm like i'm like you actually
believed that if you paid half a million
dollars to somebody that they would
actually give you magic powers
i don't know that's to me that just
seems really
i just don't know like i don't know how
people got more money than sense that's
as my grandma used to say no what i was
gonna say about uh l ron hubbard i found
this great quote
uh
saying he says that uh body thetans will
hang around people they'll see a woman
who's pregnant and follow her down the
street
tina's asking didn't leah remini make it
to ota i don't think she get made it to
ota
i can't remember if she did or not i
think she had a high i think she went up
on a bridge pretty high but i don't
think it was ota she might have though
think so
no but yeah because i think that was one
of the things that made her like want to
leave is that she took the ot8 thing and
that's that's where you find out about
xenu and all that [ __ ] right or no you
found that oak t3 oh okay so maybe
okay so maybe after she learned about
that she was like what the hell is this
[ __ ] you learn
[Laughter]
you find out pretty early on uh about
xenu
i think it's ot3
but the thing is is that most most
scientologists never even make it to ot1
they don't have the money
well yeah and then and honestly nowadays
particularly scientology only wants
people with like lots of lunch and a lot
of the people that are involved in it
don't really want to go up on a bridge
they just they don't want to go up in
levels they it's for them it's a i think
it's mostly just a
it's it's a social club i think for a
lot of them and it's a social club of a
bunch of larpers yeah they all get to
hang out and be weird together
and like stare at each other and try to
like figure out where they are on the
tone scale they're basically trekkies
except not as cool
they're much stupider yeah
i think they're smart though they're
like they're like anything else and that
is
that i know that makes me so that makes
me so angry well that was one of the
things that made me really angry when i
worked with a bunch of them it was just
kind of like i was like you really are
stupid but you think that
but they think they're more intelligent
than everybody and i'm just like i'm not
the dumbass that just paid like 500 000
yeah for this crap
okay so
don't look at me like i'm stupid when i
got when i got out of the army i moved
to um right outside cambridge
massachusetts you know we had all the
ivy league schools there man [ __ ]
harvard tufts mit
there were some smart people there man
but
it was amazing to me how much a [ __ ]
hardcore college town like that like
boston is
how how how similar it is in a way to
look like an army town
college students are kind of like at the
same level as [ __ ] soldiers in an
army town they just they're everywhere
[ __ ] people are sick up
they're kind of like the idiots of the
town or the rubes
but you know it's the young kids with a
bunch of money [ __ ]
that [ __ ] there man
i had a hard time [ __ ] believing that
they were intelligent [ __ ] from some
of the ones that some of the [ __ ] that i
saw go down in clubs
and not real [ __ ] skilled man [ __ ]
well there are different kinds of
intelligence i guess yeah
the mit the mit people they impressed me
the most they but it was all math math
skills and [ __ ] no social skills
[ __ ]
cringy man [ __ ] cringey but they they
were smart they were smart
uh they weren't smart enough to know how
to [ __ ]
do color combinations with their [ __ ]
clothes or anything well like i said
that's a different kind of intelligence
they weren't smart enough to [ __ ] and
those two kinds of intelligences don't
usually go together
that's not all that's not always true
but couldn't get laid to save their
lives half of them
most of them
i don't i don't have this i don't have
this thing where let's elite people and
this and that most of them are [ __ ]
dumbasses they're rich kids and it's the
[ __ ] it's a social club for most of
them there are smart people there
but most of them are just rich people
that's all it's a social class social
club
tyler the guy sorry so tyler the guy
said reach the highest level of
scientology and you get to fight bowser
and save the princess
[Laughter]
yeah but what i was going to say is that
in certain ways i those ivy league
college students were in some ways kind
of like the scientologists where
galaxy brain [ __ ] super smart but no
[ __ ]
not really it's just
their courses told them that they were
very smart but not no
experience you know and scientology is
kind of like that i ran into a table of
them one time i didn't know what i was
dealing with just before i really knew
anything about scientology remember that
starbucks yeah
the [ __ ] weirdest thing ever man
and it's like running into [ __ ]
larpers in their 50s and 60s and i
didn't know what they were larping
it was [ __ ] weird man they all pulled
out phones and started taking pictures
of me
when i when i was like what the [ __ ] you
do what are you talking about and they
started because they thought i was going
to attack them
yeah you know that's one thing they yeah
that's one thing i was like i've never
seen that before they're all taking f
this is
you know yeah people would take
photographs of [ __ ] but that wasn't in
the common culture at that time yeah
scientologist came up with the damn
pulling the phone on a [ __ ] yeah
they're like five of them all and i'm
like what are you guys like the [ __ ]
ciao like what the [ __ ]
yeah they all thought they would like
the cia
i wish like if they've done that to me
i'd have been like
i didn't know what i was dealing with
i thought it was the business people at
first
and then i said is this something he's
some kind of [ __ ]
no they want you to do something to them
so so that they can sue you yeah is this
some kind of federal agents what are
these [ __ ] people like if you started
throwing rocks at them which would be my
first uh my first
uh you know desire uh then they will get
all their lawyers and they'll sue you
into it and the women were all had that
librarian
vibe to them and the dudes all had that
dressed up redneck [ __ ]
vibe to them i'm dressed up right now
you [ __ ] redneck dressed up and [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know i mean he thinks he's
just no way to describe it
thank you david june
happy birthday jenny thank you thanks
for the thousands of hours worth of
content i know a kid probably is
thousands of hours at this point you're
easily the hardest working person on the
youtube platform right you'll be
reincarnated into someone equally as
badass thank you so much that's one of
the nicest things that anyone's ever
said to me
oh we had to like some dead air there
but yeah um
so
what were you saying oh about
scientology yeah
that's that's why they do that though
and it's like and you can see it too in
the um
some of the views like angry gay popes
videos and like some other people that
um every time you say something sideways
then they all pull their phones out one
they're trying to intimidate you yeah uh
and two they're waiting for you to like
they're trying to piss you off so that
you'll hit them and then they can sue
you yeah cause they get off on that they
get a [ __ ]
lawyer
yeah and like i said they just like to
intimidate people as well but even
though they're and they're nerdy nerdy
nerdy that's what i mean it's like um
okay
[Laughter]
whatever you say
i'm just
having worked around them for
almost a year i'm just i don't know i'm
just kind of over it at this point i'm
just like nope i'm too old to deal with
that [ __ ]
um
so
the thing about this though
about
reincarnation um
i kind of feel like
some people have
said that uh oh it would explain stuff
like um
you know people going into like that
past life regression [ __ ] with the
hypnosis which i'm not sure if i buy
that because
people say all kind of crazy [ __ ] under
hypnosis depending on what their
therapist asks them i mean look at all
the satanic panic [ __ ] which we talked
about before like some of the [ __ ] those
kids came up with
um
uh some people said oh it can explain
child prodigies you know maybe this kid
was like some super badass whoever like
in a past life
and a lot of their [ __ ] was left over so
that's why they're like much much
smarter i've even seen
some people saying oh this might explain
um
you know gender dysphoria like things
like that where people think they're
you know not the sex or born or whatever
it's like because of reincarnation and
i'm just kind of like yeah
um it's it's just this kind of whole
thing and some people have said too that
um
maybe this would explain why some people
just seem to have like really shitty
luck all the time because they're a
really shitty person at their past life
and it's like they're getting you know
they're reincarnated and they're kind of
like it's like victim blade like that's
what i mean it's like see
the greeks used to think that you're i
know you're deformed because you did
something evil well yeah and i kind of
feel like yeah well i think that was
kind of like a lot of the medieval
christians believed that kind of [ __ ]
too because they said if you look [ __ ]
up then then you are [ __ ] up yeah and
it's weird because that
i you know i don't think that is
persistent anymore but i think it does
kind of like linger that belief
because if you see
even if you watch i don't know why i
just thought of this but if you watch
like um yeah i don't know like cartoon
movies or something like that
um a lot of times like the the bad guys
will always be kind of like ugly or
funny looking whereas like the good guys
are always like these blandly
you know what i mean what you want me to
get into this well you know yeah because
i can i can okay i can i can i can
justify some of this [ __ ]
people in general are are kind of how
they appear
um now if there's [ __ ] health issues
you know i mean [ __ ] diseases then
you know that's beyond the control of
that person
sometimes bad people [ __ ] look
frightening one because they [ __ ]
made themselves very strong okay so they
got kind of big all right
and then because they were constantly
fighting their faces got all [ __ ]
scarred up [ __ ] missing teeth and
broken noses and [ __ ] scars battle
scars dudes that are [ __ ] always in
and out of armies and [ __ ]
[ __ ] if they were fighting you know
[ __ ] over the millennia or whatever
you know any period of time they'd have
battle scars on them so
being a badass takes to takes a physical
toll
on people
so when you see a person who's all beat
up battle scarred you know it's a bad
[ __ ] you know
um
so that's partly what they're or he's a
real [ __ ] and he gets his ass kicked
a lot that too but
you'd be able to see though if he was
kind of a weak person you know what i
mean and
and but hostile and all beat up then why
are they beating up this week dude you
know what i mean what kind of troubles
he's getting into you can read a person
you know
mentalists do it for a living you can
read a person
and you know [ __ ] you can you can
look at a woman and [ __ ] tell a lot
about her by just you know her build
what she's wearing how she carries
herself her age just everything you know
you can you know you pretty young woman
you can [ __ ]
spot that right off
and you know by what she's wearing and
how she's acting you can [ __ ] go down
the list and go you know when she's
middle class she's [ __ ] this and that
she probably likes this she probably
listens to that band because that shirt
she's wearing she probably likes this so
you know you can you can
you can read a person very well you know
so appearances are factors you can tell
where somebody comes from everything
what they're thinking how they feel how
they see themselves
uh being superficial is a skill
um now
a medieval person might see those you
know those conjoined twins the ones that
look like a spider they had the two
dudes remember that that was the
weirdest that one dude walked like a
damn spider
he looked [ __ ] up well he was [ __ ]
up though too you know what i mean they
lived a conjoined life they both
were mentally um
stunted um they didn't have normal
intelligence
so
they were kind of how they looked also
it was just you know well and i think
what ends up happening too is that if
you're born and you look really [ __ ]
up and it's no fault of yours it's just
like a random birth defect or something
then people are gonna generally treat
you like crap
which is probably gonna make you maybe
like a little bit of a bitter person
well those guys weren't though those
guys no i'm just saying i'm in general
that's something that could happen so
it's almost kind of like a feedback loop
those guys were treated pretty well but
they were they were you know they had
child like minds you know they had uh
mental problems uh they were mentally
handicapped so they weren't fully aware
of what was you know i mean what's it it
was it was a normal situation to them
to be a conjoined well yeah they didn't
know they looked like a spider they
didn't know any different no they're
sitting there joking around having fun
but uh dumb you know
that we'll see that's what i kind of
think about it's like from our point of
view you're like oh man that's so [ __ ]
up and it's like
to live like that but it's like they
don't know how to live any other way
they've always been like that all they
did was just [ __ ] talk to each other
and joke around with each other
so to them it's not weird it's only
weird because other people pointed out
that it was weird yeah so that made me
feel a little bit better about it i
guess
so
my advice to y'all
is that people are in general how they
appear
you know their appearance the appearance
indicates
it's an indicator of how they are as
people
unless you're talking about even when it
comes to [ __ ] physical damage that's
another clue that something hap
something happened why did it happen you
know what's this person bit into
everything leaves a trace
you know what i mean
yeah
sorry somebody in the comments is going
under the name tom's dead
it says have a good birthday jennifer
have some turkey necks on the big day
they'll guarantee you another year
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
your dad is in this comments i think
ilsa came on here earlier she said she
was happy to be catching a live stream
and she said oh it's the new house this
is actually still the old house it's
your house uh we just haven't moved
because the internet isn't set up at the
new house yet
it won't be set up until tuesday so
we're still streaming from here but
obviously we've moved my most of the
stuff over to the new house but we just
have to stream from here for a couple
times before
uh we get everything set up over there
so yeah so
there's this dude uh i read a lot about
this guy every time you like read about
reincarnation this guy comes up a lot
his name is dr ian stevenson he's a
psychiatrist
and um he's dead now but uh his he was
really interested in reincarnation but
his big thing
was that
he was really into
studying like little kids
um around the ages from like two to five
that would say weird [ __ ] like
would come out and say things like you
know remember when i was an old man or
something like that and would sort of
like try to regress them
so he even like founded something it was
called i think it was originally called
the division of personality studies
and um yeah and he ran it for many years
so that's kind of like
he wrote like a bunch of papers about it
that i guess were published um and he
basically said i'm not trying to prove
it because the thing about reincarnation
is that is
would there be any way to prove that it
was true
because
basically people that believe in it and
i'm gonna get into like some
uh some cases of it that i found like
here and there
but it's usually something like a kid
you know will come up to their mom and
say some spooky [ __ ] you know what i
mean like remember when i died or some
[ __ ] like that
and then like the parents will be like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about and
then the kid will start talking about
hey i used to be this guy and he got
shot or whatever
and uh then sometimes they'll like look
into the history it's kind of like some
of the like episodes of haunting where
they have like a ghost story and that's
what i heard was about the fighter pilot
guy from yeah we're gonna talk about
that one yeah james lighting we'll
probably talk about him last okay um but
there well there's a lot of question
about that though because the thing
about it is that
every time you read about some of these
reincarnation stories
it's always like more complicated than
it sounds
like because sometimes it sounds like
really awesome like because you're kind
of like oh he said this and that and
then they went back and checked and
you know that there really was that
person and they were but
what happens in a lot of cases not all
of them yeah it's it's kind of like
satanic panic all over again where
they you know they the kid says some
spooky [ __ ]
the parents start believing maybe this
kid is a reincarnation of whoever
and then they take them to some
therapist who believes in reincarnation
and then they start kind of like
leading making sure that it happens
yeah and like i said i'm not saying all
the cases are like that but a lot of the
kind of um more famous ones are
absolutely that which um you know which
is kind of a shame because uh and
honestly in most of the cases that
sounded kind of compelling most of those
come from
uh you know eastern religions come from
like india and stuff like that where
belief in reincarnation is not that
unusual like pretty much everybody
believes in it and it's just kind of
like taken for granted
and there's not a huge amount of
documentation on them either
but i was sure i was thinking about this
when i was reading all these different
cases i'm like would there even be
a scientific way to definitively prove i
mean i guess you could prove like one
person that was was reincarnated you
know to an extent
so let's say like some kid came your kid
came up to you and said like some spooky
[ __ ] about
you know
remember when i was this old man named
this or that the other thing and then
if you could
rule out that kid finding out about that
any other way
um
and you had and you had like independent
verification that that person really
existed that this really happened to
that person this that the other thing
then maybe that
would maybe not prove it definitively
but it would be like pretty compelling
but the thing about it is that there's
always
if that information is out there there
might there might always be like another
way they could have obtained that
information other than
them being
reincarnated as that person do you know
what i'm saying yeah if that person
existed there's always another way of
getting that information
that's why i don't know if it can ever
be proved definitively
you know what i'm saying yeah
oh you've clammed up all of a sudden
i'm thinking about it you're thinking
about it thinking about it and alcohol's
getting me
[Laughter]
yeah so sorry i'm just trying to think
thinking about what
i can't remember any time before i was
born
no i can't either there's a vast expanse
of time in the before
no
time and then there's a vast expanse of
time in the after you die
but for some reason i still can't
imagine myself not existing
i'm trying to imagine most people can't
i'm trying to think yeah i'm trying to
imagine non-existence
i think it's within the nature of
non-existence that you can't actually
imagine well something what is the
chances of there being all that time in
the past
all right and then all that time in the
future and i was born just me
what are the chances of that [ __ ]
i'm seeing through these eyes you know
what i mean what are the chances that
that would have happened
yeah but see you're looking at it in the
wrong way this i okay
um
you're only special
to you because you're you because you're
aware of yourself think of it this way
it's more likely i should have never
existed think of it well yeah well
that's true of everybody though right
think of it this way
um how likely is it that you will pick
all six lottery numbers not very likely
um however
six lottery numbers will be picked you
know what i'm saying um yeah and
afterwards people be like oh well you
won or whatever but it's like the
chances of any one person winning
very very remote but somebody will win
um so that's like you know so but and
when you win like you feel like oh
you're this big lucky person but it's
just like random and the same thing is
like true of people
you seem special because it's like oh
you're here now and you've lived like
your whole entire life and everything
like that but you could have been any
number of other people and you wouldn't
know any different because you would
have been that person you know what i'm
saying am i expressing myself very
excited
[Laughter]
it didn't answer the question i'm just
thinking that it's very odd that i'm me
it's not though very odd
like i said you could have a chance you
could have been any number of other
people but you wouldn't have known any
different no what would it have it's
more like with than then you've seen i
could have been somebody else
that's like reincarnation
no that's not i was not that's not what
i mean yeah i was not somebody else i
exist
all right i'm seeing through my own eyes
i have a point of view all right
it's very unlikely that that happened it
would have been far more likely that i
would have never have ever been would
have ever existed
you know what i mean non-existence is
more likely
well yeah like i said that's true that's
true of everyone right
but something's got to come up like i
said it's just like the lottery numbers
the chances of any
one sequence of lottery numbers coming
up is remote you just said one sequence
will come up so you're just saying i'm
an emergent property of everyone else
everything but what was the chance that
that that one happened to be me
it just just you know see no you're
looking at it the wrong way you're
looking at it exactly the right way i'm
looking at it right through my eyes
that's exactly the right part that's
exactly the right way to look at it
but see i think the problem is that even
when i was a baby though it was still me
well yeah but that's true of everybody
the problem is that i think everybody
thinks of themselves as special because
you can't think of yourself any other
way because you don't know what it's
like to have someone else's point of
view because you've never had anyone
else's point of view you only had your
own so
to you everything seems like
you know oh my gosh what are the chances
of me being born i'm like well
i to me that seems like a meaningless
question
because it's like it was just like
random that i was but it just happened
to be me you know what i mean
i think uh i think
i don't think we can totally grasp it
because i'm not sure we really
understand much about space time and the
space-time continuum right you know
um
it might be that there's a certain part
of us that has always existed outside of
space-time
and we're just manifesting in this
space-time
for right now true you know what i'm
talking about yeah so in other words
there might be
i i kind of believe in what the whole
poltergeist thing and the things that i
saw [ __ ] with the out-of-body
experience
is that there's a certain part of us
that is outside the flow of space and
time
that's possible it's just kind of a
universal singularity
all right
and it
you can inhabit a body
at times
i think you choose it that's going into
the reincarnation thing but i don't
believe their lives share any
memory of one another
it's like a total reboot
of a character like playing a video game
yeah like you die and you just get kind
of like yeah and then you pop in another
game and you're somewhere else you're
not even you're not even playing final
fantasy anymore now i'm in miss pac-man
now i'm in this pac-man right yeah it's
gonna be some [ __ ] like that
i think it's good which
the part i think the part of us that is
you or that is us
exists mostly in another dimension
that's what i think
and it's outside space and time
hmm you know yeah and that's where it's
kind of like where your daemon is that's
where the real you is
the greeks called that place the ploroma
the places from which gods come from
yeah all right
and that they've tried to describe it
the plural the places where god where
gods and angels
and i guess souls come from
where they are where that is
it's separate from
physical space and time
that's just my instincts of it my
instincts might be wrong but
tyler the guy says i hope i don't end up
in grand theft auto
[Laughter]
right i've i'd end up with some [ __ ]
shitty videos i probably just i probably
end up in like asteroids or something
like that
or joust
[Laughter]
all i know are the old video games
i know new ones i just haven't really
played them
um
yeah so i i don't know it's just
it's kind of hard for me to articulate
like what i'm talking about but
it does seem like once you're here
it seems like oh well that's the only
possible outcome but before you were
born there was like zillions of
different possible outcomes it just
happened that you were the one that
popped out you know what i mean it's
just like a whole series of random
coincidences like you said in an
emergent property
i'm in emergent property i'm okay with
that
[Laughter]
i'm okay with that david june said tom
reference final fantasy had no clue he
was a fan a long time ago a long time
ago yeah yeah i was like what have you
been playing lately
um
alien isolation
i've been playing alien isolation still
haven't finished [ __ ]
what is it the fallout
one before that's a massive game yeah i
think it's fallout 3 fallout 4 4 yeah
four i think the one before
76.
i'm uh doing on the far harbor
that's a cool ass game yeah you can play
that one forever i even like to sit
there and watch just watch him walking
around in his [ __ ] mech suit or
whatever yeah going
yeah that noise it makes
that kind of creaky noise um never did
finish the doom
oh yeah you were playing that yeah i had
to fight that damn big old spider
monster
and the [ __ ] thing's coming everybody
have spider monsters there's a game
there's a new dune that just came out
and i'm not going to buy that one until
i finish this one
maternal i think is what was it maybe i
forgot what it's called i played all
those dooms over the years i [ __ ]
still have the uh the re uh master dooms
like doom one and doom [ __ ] two and
[ __ ] doom 64. you could buy all the
old ones
the old ones i think the old ones are
better than the new ones in a certain
way
more charm to them
prepper pov says my mom is definitely
pissed at the odds of me being her son
of all people
[Laughter]
how'd i end up with you that's probably
why i didn't have any kids because it's
like i'm too i'm like i'm not doing that
crap [ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] who knows
what'll what'll turn up uh david june
says i have alien is it any good
it's all right yeah sorry it's a hiding
survival game survival horror game
you can't really fight
she's a girl she can't fight
well plus they're aliens and they'll
just like [ __ ] well you can't fight
the alien at all you have to fight
people
and uh you have to fight robots well
that makes it harder yeah
it's mostly a stealth game you got to do
a lot of hiding
hiding and creeping and trying
finding stuff and
uh you can hear that damn alien jumping
about down out of the ceiling and you
gotta use your [ __ ] tracker to try to
see where it's coming and it [ __ ]
could come out of nowhere at any time
man jump up out of the ceiling get you
yeah yeah he's an alien yeah they're
talking about um
jack torrance in the shining
and if he was perhaps a reincarnation of
the old caretaker oh
no i don't think so
i thought
i thought he was just like the current
manifestation
or it or i thought it was like a
purgatorial loop is what i thought
you know what i'm saying the
the movie still kind of
follows
the book pretty well
it's just that you're seeing it from uh
from wendy's point of view
that's the way that book would seem if
it was just windy yeah like if you
didn't know what was going on in
everyone's head you didn't know like the
history of the hotel right
and uh
jack was just uh
in the book jack was just [ __ ]
uh
under the spell of the damn house
he was you know
what he called obsessed with it
and he was following in grady's
footsteps
that's really all it was i mean the
house essentially like absorbed him yeah
well that's what it did to people i mean
that's how it got its power right it
kind of just
grady wasn't possessing him was it
not really i don't think it was grady i
think it was the hotel grady was the
ghost of grady was there though yeah but
that was what he but he was like that
was the hotel's manifestation just like
just like the bartender
was the hotel manifesting no i mean
talking about the book not the movie oh
i haven't read the book in the book in
the book i think i think grady was uh
grady was was uh
manipulating jack a lot
yeah
for the house
yeah
yeah yeah it was doing like uh it was
kind of like
one of its emissaries yeah
too
to do what it wanted i haven't read the
book in a long time
to answer those questions you got to
read that book again
because um
um
kubrick stanley kubrick would have would
have [ __ ] been pretty
loyal to the book
a lot of people say well no there's many
differences in the book not really there
are some differences
like you know who gets killed and
uh you know hallerin halloran gets
killed and somebody had to die in the
movie though
and you know there wasn't a maze in the
book there were hedge animals
but in general it's still that same
story yeah but it would just be if it
was that that's what wendy would have
saw
in the book nothing else
saunders says watch jenny's we need to
talk about kevin review today yep it was
a good decision not to have children
yeah if you're ever kind of thinking
maybe i don't really want kids yeah why
don't you uh go watch we need to talk
about kevin or um
read the book baby teeth
and then see if you want to have kids
after that you will not
[Laughter]
it's terrible
but yeah so
um no the bartender wasn't the devil the
bartender was the house yeah i think
that i think the bartender
was the hotel it was like the it was the
spirit of the hotel yeah
and the hotels the whole the hotel's
thing was like to trap ghosts exploit
people's weaknesses to get them to
manipulate them into doing what it
wanted and what it wanted was it wanted
danny because he had the shining yeah
the hotel collat the hotel collected
spirits yeah for its own power it would
amass its own power
and there's a lot of stuff there about
being consecrated ground and
blood consecration
fighting those indians you know early on
and
it was like a palace for the [ __ ]
rich and powerful
[ __ ] oligarchs you know
and [ __ ] it was kind of like a temple
of sacrifice temple of doom
yeah yeah pretty cool now somebody said
that
the made for tv movie was bad yeah maybe
tv movie it was bad i agree she didn't
like it i liked it oh it was bad
but it was uh much much closer to the
book but that's why i didn't like it
yeah i love the book and i love
kubrick's
movie
i did not like
the stephen king like mini series
adaptation because it was almost exactly
like the book exactly it was like
literal
and i think that's why it wasn't very
good
well special effects and the acting and
just the the sets and it's just you know
you can't really do that especially on a
tv budget
there wasn't really any artistry too
there wasn't any
subtlety to it
yeah which is what i didn't like about
it and like i said it followed the book
just like slavishly which i think was a
mistake it was kind of like the stand it
made for tv staff yeah but you know some
somebody sent us the new copy of the
stand remastered it's a lot better than
the newer version
but the the old v8 vhs version of it
[ __ ] vhs transfer it's on youtube
it's looking terrible
thank you david june y'all could do a
weekly show on the shining yeah we
probably could actually we've seen it so
many times i've probably seen the
shining more than any other movie ever
and i've said this before but it's like
if if you ask me right now hey you want
to watch the shining yep
i'd watch the shining every day
that i'd not be bothered at all
tila said jenny are you going to watch a
horror night in october 31 days of
october i actually did think about doing
that um i had it all planned out but
then this whole moving situation came up
and i said [ __ ] man i don't think i'm
gonna have time and we gotta make nearly
a hundred sure to do that yeah and we
have to do we have a huge like a huge
order of shirts for a concert for
absolution
and we have like two weeks to do it like
less than two weeks less than two weeks
now yeah so yeah we have to make a [ __ ]
ton of shirts so what i decided to do as
a compromise was i'm gonna do extra
horror movie reviews the week of
halloween so it'll be like from sunday
to sunday because i was like i don't
think i'm gonna have time to do ones
like for the whole month well hi look at
her
doing this
her little face pops up
she wants to go outside okay
you be careful pookie okay
i bet she doesn't want to go
he puts her clothes on and then she goes
to the door and she's like never mind i
don't want to
i'm like i don't uh
i'm still waiting to see how she's going
to react like to the new house
she's never lived anywhere with stairs
before
so
she's gonna be wigging out i don't know
what she's gonna do we're trying to like
decide where to put her little tree at
because she loves that tree
and she's gonna be flipping out the
whole time we like drive over there and
her
in her carrier because she's gonna be
like [ __ ] i'm going to the vet because
that's the only place she's ever been in
the carrier
this is the only house she's ever known
i think she was um because we got her
when she was really little like only six
or seven weeks old
and she'd been in someone's house like
in someone's garage because they found
her in the backyard and they just like
put her in a carrier in the garage
um
and
then she you know when she came to our
house she hasn't been anywhere but that
so i don't
i don't know like how she's going to
react i'm kind of worried about it i'm
more worried about that than anything
like how pooky's going to react to the
new house i'm not worried about the
house otherwise but it's just
did you like
i told you did it again i told you
she always does that the first time
she's like oh my god oh my god i should
go outside it's really important and
then like you open the door and she's
like yeah [ __ ] it
i just want i just wanted to see if you
would get up and open the door i think
she's [ __ ] with you yep
tyler the guy says i've always loved the
stand miniseries from the 90s but the
book was even better when i actually
read it yeah the book's better i mean
the books are always better um you know
we talked about this before about
stephen king's adaptations i mean there
are actually like a lot of really good
stephen king adaptations but
again [ __ ] that works in a book doesn't
work in a movie all the time so you have
to kind of know the difference the
limitations of each medium yeah you know
what i mean we got to get this show
cracking though well i don't have that
much more as you know i just have like
cases okay i just kind of started
talking about some cases
i mean some of these and like i said
some of these are just kind of vague i
just went and day's catching up with me
man got like alcohol is getting me and i
was like going oh starting to go
sideways yeah we've been like work our
sleep patterns have been like so [ __ ]
up well because what's been happening is
that
we've been
one i've been waking up
like at 4am every morning for whatever
reason like assaulting me and [ __ ] well
yeah that's it like assaulted me at four
o'clock i didn't assault you at four
o'clock in the morning you were awake
too yeah but it wasn't four that was it
was six this morning
but the last um
couple days i've been waking up at like
four in the morning and then i can't go
back to sleep um not because i'm upset
but i'm just kind of like oh i gotta do
this and i gotta oh i gotta remember to
write that down and i gotta do this and
that i'm like thinking of all the stuff
i gotta do oh i you know i gotta drive
here and do this and then so it gets
light finally and i just like roll out
of bed i get in the office and do
whatever it has to do and then i was
just like i got to go to the new house i
got to do this i got to do that so it's
just kind of like we have so much [ __ ]
going on
that
we just be we just like work and work
and work and work and work all day and
then by the time it's like
like last night i think i was dozing off
at like 8 30.
like i think i still i think i managed
to stay awake until like 9 30. because
we watched we watched the new uh shutter
just put the first episode of season
three of creep show up so i watched that
and then i tried to like read a little
bit and then i was just kind of like
and i think it was nine o'clock and i
was like i can't stay awake anymore
so then this morning i think i woke up
at 5 30. so we're like
we've just been going to sleep really
early and waking up really early and
just
working all day and the house has stairs
so we've have to carry heavy [ __ ] up and
down the stairs like all day long
unloading and unloading trucks me like
getting up on ladders and [ __ ] like that
like painting and [ __ ] like that so you
know we're all sore and bruised and [ __ ]
like that
what's up puke
uh sandra said will you let pookie and
beijing out on a leash in the beginning
to show them everything
no i'll just walk out there with them
yeah we'll probably just go they don't
go far yeah like when they go outside
they mostly if they go outside they just
sit on the porch yeah they'll walk
around the house that's it they just
walk around the house they'll sit in the
bushes like on the side of the house or
they'll just like sit on the porch and
like look at each other yeah they don't
really go
um they know better they've seen dogs
and seen animals and stuff so they stay
up near the house so yeah so if she does
want to go outside
then we'll just go out with her thank
you zach hope you don't have insomnia
like i had last year went up losing 10
pounds and had heart palpitations for a
day at one point at 24 years old for
[ __ ] sake
yeah i don't think it's that i just
think i am sleeping it's just that for
whatever reason i'm just like waking up
really early and then i'm just kind of
like
i'm just always thinking about [ __ ] i
gotta do you know like oh i'm making a
list in my head it's like oh this is the
stuff i gotta do when i get up
so
okay so this first case that i want to
talk about
this is this is the kind of thing
that
makes me
because if this is the low bar that
people that like believe in
reincarnation if this is the low bar
that you have to clear
see this is the kind of thing so there's
this guy he's a psychiatrist right and
his name is uh brian weiss and he had
written he wrote a book called many
lives many masters
uh so
he apparently his big reincarnation
awakening like he didn't believe in it
beforehand or so he said
but he meets this patient who is only
known as catherine because obviously
they can't say her real name is
um now she hadn't believed in past lives
either but then they did um like a hip
hypnosis like a regression now i don't
think cool because there's two different
things like sometimes when you do
hypnosis they just regress you back to
like your childhood
right like to see if some trauma or some
[ __ ] happened to you back then
but
past lives is when you're like go back
before your birth and just like yeah i
was a you know civil war
soldier or whatever so it's that kind of
thing so
he started regressing her back for
whatever reason
and then um
she apparently started coming up with
all of these
past lives now
the one that she came up with that
apparently impressed him a lot was
apparently she said she'd been alive in
ancient egypt now the proof of this
was all the proof of this that she gave
was when she was under hypnosis she
basically just said how they made
mummies like how they dried the bodies
out
and
you know they put the bodies in like the
brine or whatever for 30 days and then
they wrap them and stuff and i'm like
well everybody knew that i know how to
do that like you know i've never done it
but i know like i've read about how to
do it so it's like that's not proof that
i was alive back then that's just proof
that i can read or you know watch a
history channel documentary so i don't
really know
um and apparently she was like uh at a
museum once and they were taught that
like the tour guide was talking
something about egypt and she like
corrected them and she turned out she
was right
but um this kind of reminded me too
somebody was saying that uh way earlier
about how
um you know maybe between lives you have
to like wait in a waiting room like in
beetlejuice you know what i mean like in
the waiting room with everyone with the
shrunken head guy
um
this woman also said
that between the lives
um
there was like a space like a liminal
sort of space that she was hanging out
in
like while she was between bodies i
guess
um and she said that her
that she knew she was there and that her
son's spirit was what was there
and there was um because i guess her son
had died of like some kind of heart
deformity
and um i guess
that
no i think that hit no i think the
doctor's son had died of that and then
she told him
oh your son is here and he died of that
heart thing
like she said that to him under hypnosis
and he was like yeah i never told her
that my son died
although
again that's something that probably
could be found out in another way
i don't know
um she says that happened like that was
before the internet and nobody could
just google it but still i mean
information like that is still out there
you know what i'm saying and
unless you can completely dis discount
every single other way of gaining
information
which is would be really hard to do
well i guess you could say
stuart hameroff would say that you know
the quantum
soul theory
could account for a lot of things kind
of like that people call psychic
abilities
you know i mean your quantum
consciousness which is like a cloud of
these super
well
there it's a cloud of quantum particles
in superposition
kind of acting like your soul you know
yeah well that can come in contact and
entangled with somebody else near you
and so
maybe it's a possibility you could
have a
a level of communications that's not
really conscious between the between the
brains i'm talking about in other words
the brains
the people are not conscious of it but
their subconsciouses are talking to each
other like a psychic level
so maybe she picked up that information
psychically from him
well we've kind of talked about that
when we talked about like uh poltergeist
activity particularly like the enfield
poltergeist case when you were talking
about janet janet could know things that
she shouldn't have known about the old
guy that died in the house and
everything like that and how we were
saying that maybe it wasn't the actual
old guy haunting the house it was just
her like somehow psychically picking up
on picking up
the memories place memories because it's
kind of floating around out there maybe
and maybe some more outside of space
time she could see it in the past
you know what i'm talking about yeah she
her subconscious could see the past
slightly
maybe that's what it is well and maybe
that's what if that's possible maybe
that could explain like reincarnation
[ __ ] too because if the information's
just kind of floating around out there
in the ether you think you did it but
it's actually something and you can kind
of like to like like you would tune in a
radio station and you just kind of tuned
in and it was real clear for a minute
and you saw this whole thing and you're
like hey maybe that's a memory maybe
that happened to me maybe that's not
what it was but maybe it didn't happen
to you maybe you just like picked it up
from somebody else's memory yeah
although like i said
i don't know it to me it just kind of
seems like
because
everything that i've ever heard about
reincarnation they're just like well
basically it's mostly you know if
anybody remembers this [ __ ] it's usually
like when they're little kids and then
they
then they can't remember it anymore it
doesn't like make any impact on their
lives later
so
in that way like in in practice it
doesn't really matter like where the
information came from like whether you
obtained it
through like through psychic means out
of the ether like a radio station or
whether you got it through that person's
soul entering your body or whatever um
because in the end the the result is not
any different yeah you get what i'm
saying
so i guess it doesn't yeah but knowing
the mechanism would help
it would i'm not saying it wouldn't but
i'm just saying that in practice it
wouldn't really make a difference that's
all that's all i was saying because it's
it's not that that's kind of the thing
about it is like it just really doesn't
seem
all that useful not that it necessarily
would have to be it just seems like
one of life's oddities man yeah it's
just like yeah it's just pretty weird
yeah so um all right so now we have this
other psychiatrist from the university
of virginia named jim tucker and he also
studies reincarnation now like i said a
lot of these stories are from
psychiatrists psychologists therapist
stuff like that who actually do believe
in it um you know so
take that you know you so you might want
to take some of the stories to the grain
of salt because since they already
believe in it they may
be asking leading questions when people
are under hypnosis you know i'm not
saying they are but you know i'm just
saying you have to
leave that open as a possibility
so one of his patients was a little boy
named sam and sam is supposedly the
reincarnation of his own
grandfather
now
allegedly this kid had never seen a
picture of his grandfather until he was
four years old
after his grandmother died
his parents brought out the you know the
photo album
and uh the kid was looking at the
pictures
and he sees a picture of his grandpa's
car and he points to it he says that's
my car
right so they're kind of like
all right well maybe maybe this kid is
uh you know maybe there's something to
it
now
i guess his parents were baptists or
whatever and they didn't like believe in
reincarnation
um but she thought it was intriguing
enough
that she asked the kid if he remembered
anything else
like you know oh that's your car like
what else was going on back then
uh the the other thing the kid said was
that my sister was turned into a fish by
bad men
and then they found out well this kind
of freaked the kid's mother out because
what happened was that the sister of the
grandfather
um was actually murdered and the dudes
threw her body into a river
um
so
i don't know so i guess so at that point
like she took the kid to the therapist
like for past life regression and he
came up with some other stuff like about
you know that apparently kind of
jived with what the grandfather was like
but
when it's a family member like that man
it could be inherited it could be
inherited or it could be maybe you
talked about the grandfather and the kid
overheard you i mean i kind of feel like
that people say oh we never talked about
that around the kid or anything like
that but i was like well
one you might have forgotten that you
talked about in front of the kid too you
might have talked about it when the kid
was within earshot and you didn't know
and the kid remembered and you know
warped things around in his mind because
kids are pretty
observant like kids are a lot more
observant than you think they are i know
what what happened with me it evidently
was never spoken around around me but i
just kind of i would think that maybe
there's a possibility that
maybe you maybe
males
would inherit
some memories from their ancestral
male lineage maybe the
maybe females inherit it through the
female lineage kind of like a way
animals would kind of remember certain
instincts or gender roles or something
maybe you're given maybe you just
inherit some
some information
i mean i'd be more i'd be probably more
inclined to believe
um
stories of quote-unquote reincarnation
within families because like you said
maybe it's some kind of genetic
you have some kind of genetic
information it needs passed around some
way how does an ant hatch nearly fully
formed
dry out and go to work like it knows
everything it knows everything already
there's no educational period
it's information is stored in it i mean
you could argue that it's kind of easy
being an aunt there's not a lot there
there's not a lot to learn it's not like
humans where it's like oh my god we're
still not but they are communicating and
they're doing true they're doing
advanced stuff
they're talking to each other
with chemicals and stuff yeah
it's just strange and they don't need to
be taught anything
so are all animals kind of like that to
a certain extent when they're the young
[ __ ] have memories
but then they're forgotten as they age
memories that help them survive
it could be yeah
i mean i think that like if you want to
say it this way but like the higher up
you go along you know if you go up into
like mammals and like you know higher
mammals and stuff probably the less
that's worth vestigial it is probably
yeah that's what i was gonna say because
you know they've they've done
experiments where animals were raised in
like isolation yeah um and they don't
you know they don't learn a lot of
things that they would learn if they had
been raised by their little animal
parents yeah you know what i'm saying so
there is some learning going on but like
i said this is with higher mammals
but still they do have some instinctual
behavior just as as humans do as well
um you know
babies are born knowing
to like you know suck milk from their
from teats
you know what i mean so humans have it
too it's just that the higher you go to
like the more complex i guess if you
want to say it like that the more
complex it is the more learning
is necessary and the more [ __ ] up
you'll be if you're deprived of it early
on like you can probably never learn it
after a certain point
um you know because we did the remember
we did that show on feral children where
you know there's there's a window of
time where if you don't learn
to speak to speak if you don't learn a
language within a certain like before
you're seven or something like that then
it's not impossible but it's really
really really difficult to um at least
have a mastery of it later on because
just that that window plasticity has
passed um and
you know things get ossified as you get
older
so like i said it's not impossible
because some feral children did actually
learn to talk later but they never had
as much of a mastery as the language of
somebody that
that was around people you know speaking
it to them like from the time they were
born you know so
i don't know it's just like really
really interesting how much of our
behavior
is
inherent and how much of it is that's
why i was kind of like interested in
doing the feral the when we did the
feral children show
because that's an experiment that you
can't do for ethical reasons but it does
actually happen sometimes
but it's interesting that
the kids basically just acted like
apes
yeah pretty much
[Laughter]
so here's another one now this one i
think i might have seen this one on a
documentary because this case sounds
very familiar
so there's a kid named lee and he lives
in the midwest
from the time he was two
he kept telling his parents
i had another house and another mommy
that's he started saying that he was two
years old
and if i was that kid's mom i'd be like
why don't you just go back to that
little mommy a little ungrateful little
brat but anyway so uh by the time he's
three years old uh he started saying
that his birthday was june 26th even
though his actual birthday was june 21st
now later he told his mom that his
middle name was co c-o-e
and that he wrote movies for a living
and that he had a daughter named
jennifer not me
uh his family asked him how old he was
they're like okay well how old were you
when you died and he said 48.
so the parents started looking into it
like they started um kind of showing him
different movies they're like which one
of these did you write
um
and lee pointed to gone with the wind
and he said i wrote that one
um
so
his parents started googling
and uh they found out that the guy that
wrote gone with the wind was named
sydney co
howard c-o-e was the middle name just
like the kid had said
his birthday was also june 26th and he
had a daughter named jennifer and he
died at 48 years old
now did the parents
know this ahead of time and just massage
this into a story or as they claim did
they not know any of this before the
kids started talking about it who knows
because like i said
that information was out there the dude
that wrote gone with the wind is not a
nobody yeah he's
not you know he's not a super celebrity
but
you can find that have been made up by
the parents that's what i mean and
honestly like watching this kind of
stuff i'm like ooh maybe i should
write a book like saying like i'll find
some like we're like little obscure
person somewhere like in some buried
history book and then i'll like say that
i'm i claim that i'm a reincarnation of
that person i'll write a book and i'll
go on the go on the paranormal circuit
and everything like that
and then i'd be like i i didn't know
about any of that like before
you know what i'm saying yeah it just
kind of seems like it would be really
easy to do how long we've been streaming
two hours and 14 minutes all right let's
go ahead and wrap this up soon
i'm getting ready to pass out
well let me do like a couple more we're
still going to talk about brady murphy
and we got to talk about that that guy
all right uh so here's this one there's
a lot of these in uh in turkey actually
so now um
so this woman named karan phil tutusmus
uh from turkey she was pregnant with a
son in the 1950s
and while she was pregnant she kept
having a recurring nightmare about this
man named salim festly
who kept showing up in her dreams with a
bloody face
now later on when she gave birth to her
son whose name was semi
as soon as the sun started to talk
he said that he was that guy festly that
she kept dreaming about
um and the son said yeah i lived uh in a
village nearby and my neighbor murdered
me that's what he said sounds familiar
yes i think i've heard this story before
too so when he was four years old semi
walked to the village that he had talked
about that festle had lived in and
talked to the dude's widow
um and apparently like i said this
happened in turkey i don't know how good
the documentation uh of is on this
but
he apparently went to the widow and told
her all about
uh festle it was like about their life
together and all this other kind of
stuff and she was like super wigged out
um
and apparently the murder claims were
corroborated festle had been shot by a
neighbor
but the neighbor said it wasn't
murderous that it was a hunting accident
a hunting accident i don't know i don't
know if it was on the accident but
that's what the neighbor said that's
what he would say wouldn't it uh semi
though he said no um what actually
happened was that we had an argument
over my mule grazing in your field and
you shot me over it or you killed me
over it that was like the whole argument
so apparently this kid kept going back
to this village and like hanging out
with the widow and the kids
because he was supposed to be their dad
and they said like for the rest of his
life like whenever he saw the dude that
had apparently murdered him he would
like throw rocks at him which
was like kind of funny
but um he said he didn't want to kill
the guy because uh it would perpetuate
the cycle of murder across multiple
lifetimes i got you so he didn't want to
do that
uh all right so let me see if there's
some other stuff because like you're
getting tired yeah man
this move is killing me
yeah i know
let me see if i can
find some shorter ones well let's talk
about um
let's talk about
bridey murphy because that's like a
really famous case and then we'll talk
about james lininger and then we'll wrap
it up okay because
tom's about to pass out but like i said
it's you know
he's been he unloaded two u-hauls like
all by himself not yesterday the day
before yesterday
wasn't there before yesterday yeah yeah
anyone ever see audrey rose yeah that's
what i was thinking of we actually
reviewed it not too long ago
that's so i thought that was sort of
sort of based on a story on a true story
yeah we we saw it it was good
it would have been better back in the
day yeah i remember really liking it
it's not really a horror movie no they
tried to make it
it's not it was they tried to make it
like on par with like the exorcist
even though it's a completely different
even though it's a difference it's a
different order it's nowhere near as
scary as the exorcist
you know
but they tried to make it a movie like
the exorcist yeah it's worth seeing
yeah i don't know if you like the
exorcist people might like it
yeah so prepper pov pointed something
out that i was thinking about too it's
like
i wonder if like people are you want to
go outside does she have a little
clothes on
i got a caller okay because she didn't
want to go yeah you better be careful
puke
what time is it oh it's quarter past
eight
yeah i always feel like um
i'd be more inclined to believe somebody
that said they were reincarnated from
somebody boring rather than um you know
that they were reincarnated for somebody
like exciting or something from like an
exciting time of history because it does
seem like a lot of people like i was
watching this bbc documentary about
reincarnation i think it was just called
previous lives or past lives or
something like that i can't remember
what it was
and um
there was a guy on there this is kind of
problematic but there was like a guy on
there who was not jewish but he claimed
that he
was reincarnated as somebody that was
like hiding from the nazis during world
war ii and i'm like
i don't know
i don't know
that just seemed like really kind of
like [ __ ] man
but uh you know and and i have heard
about there's uh at least one person
probably multiple people that say that
they're the reincarnation of anne frank
which
like i said i don't i don't know if you
want to do that don't claim to be the
reincarnation of a famous person because
you're gonna have like a lot of
competition in that area because it's
like
you know everybody everybody wants the
big ticket everybody wants to be
reincarnated as somebody like
that everybody knows
you know actually there was actually a
um
bringing up anne frank this is [ __ ]
totally off subject
there are some people that say that that
that that there was no anne frank that
that was actually a work of fiction
it was kind of like you know uh
there was an author wrote that story to
make it as a bestseller and kind of he
had photographs of a girl and everything
and just kind of made that up to make a
bunch of money i wonder if that's true
i thought that the whole thing was not
so much a hoax but more like a literary
just kind of a
cash grab
i don't know i've never heard that
remember eaters of the dead
yeah vaguely it kind of seemed like it
was a historical [ __ ] story in a
certain way the way it was written
i don't know i don't know maybe if you
guys know anything about that you can
drop in the comment section remember
hearing somebody questioned whether or
not that was actually a true story
yeah i don't know
um all right so
where oh it's okay they're still talking
about audrey's all right so let's talk
about brady murphy because this is
probably
uh this is probably the first case of
reincarnation that i read about uh back
in my old strange stories and you know
strange stories amazing facts or
whatever that book is called
um
because there's a big long thing about
the about this in there
so back in 1952
there's a woman named virginia teague
from pueblo colorado and she gets uh put
under hypnosis
by a dude named mori bernstein
now apparently after he'd put her under
hypnosis
she started speaking in an irish accent
which i've heard the tapes
it's not that great of an irish accent
yeah
um you know not not that i'm an expert
or anything but it just it didn't really
sound like that good at irish accent to
me sandra said anne frank's father
evidently survived and gave interviews
yeah i knew i thought one of them had
i remember hearing something about the
whoever had that manuscript and because
i knew they weren't all killed because i
remember reading that at school remember
somebody saying that whoever had that
manuscript and sold it to make the book
that he that there was some there's some
kind of controversy that maybe he had
made made that up or made parts of it up
i don't know i don't know enough about
it but
it'd be kind of weird there's a lot of
stuff out there like that whose origins
are kind of
cloudy you know what i mean
greenspark is saying or um anastasia i
remember an episode of unsolved
mysteries about her being reincarnated
yeah i remember that i remember seeing
something about that as well
but yeah so this woman gets put under
hypnosis starts talking in an irish
accent and saying that she is named
brady murphy that she lived in cork
ireland in the 19th century
so at this point uh the dude that
hypnotized her was like ooh let's see
what we can do with this so uh he
started doing past life regression so he
started like hypnotizing her a whole
bunch of times
um and while she was under she would
sing like irish songs she would um you
know
tell like
tales from over there uh and she said
that she was born in 1798
she said she was from protestant family
uh she said she was married to somebody
named sean bryan joseph mccarthy and
that she had died in belfast
and was buried there in 1864.
subsequently uh maureen bernstein wrote
a book called the search for brady
murphy which came out in 1956 which was
massively successful i remember this
being all over the paranormal [ __ ] like
in the 60s and 70s it was on
uh in search of i think it was it was in
all those like paranormal books like i
said it was in that strange stories
amazing facts book that i have it was
all kind of [ __ ] um
they uh changed her name to ruth simmons
in the book actually uh for reasons
which i will get into in a moment
and as i said they made recordings of a
lot of the hypnosis sessions some of
which you can listen to on youtube or in
various documentaries because i've
listened to them so if the actual irish
people go and listen to that accent
because it sounded kind of fake to me
but you know okay
so uh at this point everybody's kind of
like interested because this story had
gotten so huge so
all these reporters like went to ireland
to uh check out if this was actually a
real story was this a real person
uh so
spoiler alert they didn't find any
records
uh of anyone named bridie murphy from
that area
from that time period
uh didn't find any marriage records no
death certificates
no anything
somebody did come up with a record of a
clerk named john mccarthy working in
belfast
between 1858 and 1862 but that was about
it there was no like record of his
marriage or anything like that
uh interestingly though one reporter
actually did find a person named bridey
murphy that was but was spelled
differently bridey murphy corkel
uh but this person lived in wisconsin in
the 20th century and matter of fact
she had lived across the street from
where virginia teague grew up
so all of this stuff about bridie murphy
all this stuff it might not have even
been
virginia
you know pretending that she
that she was reincarnated as an irish
woman she was just remembering a woman
from her childhood that she had
forgotten
and hypnosis seemed to have brought it
to the surface
interestingly
even after this information came out
that a woman named bridey murphy corkel
had lived across the street from this
woman when she was a little girl and
that maybe that's where the name and
[ __ ] came from
um the book still kept selling because
everybody still believed in it
uh but then it came out that actually
virginia the woman herself who had been
hypnotized
did not believe that she had been
reincarnated at all
um
and she actually said and this is a
quote if i had known what was going to
happen i would never have laid down on
the couch
that's why they used a pseudonym in that
book because she didn't want her name
used because she didn't believe in it
i don't think she remembered that woman
living across the street or where that
name came from
but she never believed that it was
you know that she was reincarnated
um
so it turned out and i and that's what i
was saying at the beginning of this and
this is what happened with a lot of
satanic panic cases as well
is that
you have like one of this therapist who
was not licensed by the way
um
yeah i mean that's that means he's not a
real therapist yeah well that's what i
mean well a lot of these are he's just
like he was just like a businessman who
did hypnosis on the side yeah and
decided when she started doing this
crazy [ __ ] under hypnosis he's like oh
cash cow you know i don't know if he
thought that but
i mean he did make a lot of money off
that book because that book was like a
[ __ ] huge cultural phenomenon i
remember that [ __ ] being everywhere well
yeah
and honestly it's probably particularly
you know from the 50s to the 70s i feel
like that was kind of like the heyday of
like paranormal [ __ ] yeah you know
reincarnation you know ghost stories ufo
abductions like so
you know ancient aliens i mean i know
there's a lot of that around nowadays
but
there was in the 70s particularly
because i'm thinking of shows like in
search of and stuff there was really
kind of like a veneer of respectability
to it yeah because it seemed like most
people were like yeah i suppose so like
that could really happen i was even
watching like an old thing
a reincarnation that i think was from in
search ever at least it was narrated by
leonard nimoy and um you know he he
would lend his voice to it and it seemed
like oh that could totally happen well
of course man [ __ ] jim was with it
the whole [ __ ] the whole [ __ ] the
whole bridge crew was there
now well reading about this story i was
kind of like i would kind of let i don't
know if i could be hypnotized or not
but um
i would like to undergo this hypnosis
thing just i don't think that i've been
like reincarnated or anything but i just
want to see what kind of crazy [ __ ] i
come up with
jinx says i've heard that anyone you see
in a dream is someone you've seen in
real life because the brain can't make
up new face because it's all memory is
not true
i don't think yeah i don't think that's
necessarily i've heard that also
but i'm not sure if that's true because
i think i mean human brains make up
crazy [ __ ] all the time
you know what i mean
i had a dream one time was weird as a
waking dream i thought i might have been
might have been astral
and i saw a girl
a young woman a young sitting in a um
ice cream parlor in korea it was a
korean woman
and i sat down right next to her
and i realized i was in her dream and
she went up and looked at me made eye
contact and she [ __ ] panicked and she
vanished and then that dream was gone
and as i was she was i was in my dream
after that that was the weirdest [ __ ]
thing and i was under the impression
that somehow i i was in her dream and
she saw me and it woke her up that's
like dreamception yeah
i always wondered about that too it's
like what if i what if i'm sleeping and
i'm like having a dream about something
that's like what if i'm in that person's
dream yeah because i'm always dreaming
about people i don't [ __ ] know yeah i
felt like i have i felt like i had
project absolutely projected while
dreaming and i was in a lucid dream
flying over [ __ ] korea over over
seoul korea
and i was like oh yeah it's good to be
back in korea and i saw an ice cream
parlor and i went in
went in went in through the glass and
everything and was standing there and
there was a woman sitting there with her
ice cream and and i went she's dreaming
this
and i [ __ ] sat down in front of her
like that and went hey what's up she
looked at me and went
and then everything vanished not just
her
vanished and i was somewhere else and i
was like i went into her dream and then
i went on and dream and controlling like
a lucid dream of where whoever i wanted
to go at that time
and then i forgot where i went after
that
but i was awake in a dream controlling
it
elusive yeah i've had yeah what was that
i was doing that
and i saw her dream and went into it it
was just a random person in korea
huh
that's pretty that's pretty cool weird
huh but yeah i've had lots of dreams
where it's like i realized i was
dreaming that yeah yeah that's what i
was doing yeah i just didn't know i was
in somebody else's dream yeah until i
saw her
[Laughter]
yeah sorry i didn't mean to that didn't
mean to freak you out or anything well
she would i could see that she was a
dream in it
that's pretty funny yeah everybody's
saying that we should hypnotize you and
then tila says let's save it for the
halloween show hopefully they'll break
out the ouija board
we should i have a ouija board mouse
actually right here like on my other
computer we could use that
uh but yeah well yeah see because the
thing about it is i meant to i forgot to
mention this before but one of the
things that made her therapist like
convinced that this that bridey murphy
had really existed and she'd really been
like this woman had really been
reincarnated was [ __ ] like
um she described like kissing the
blarney stone and she's like yeah like
somebody has to hold you while you like
lay backward i'm like yeah but
everybody knows that like well not
everybody knows that but most people
know that that's like pretty general
knowledge
so
anything that's general knowledge like
that is not [ __ ] proof of
reincarnation i'm sorry that's it's just
that's like i said it's such a low bar
like i said i need names dates places
just information that there's no way
that you could obtain it other than by
you being reincarnated
says y'all better put a stay out of my
dreams tom sign up
yeah so now tom's going to go like
popping up and everybody's dreams going
dream invasion yeah
going like made in your damn dreams
measuring my bicep don't be doing
nothing everyone let me go like that in
everybody's dreams that'd be fun
with his [ __ ] mullet wig on
[Laughter]
light coat of body oil
flip flops
rocked up
now that you're saying it out loud
several people might actually dream that
now man
he's standing here looking at you like
see
thank you zach he said zach go come on
come on in my dream he says this reminds
me of the spongebob episode where he
goes into all his friends dreams and
then they all tell him to stop it in
person in real life at that time
somebody asked i think sondra asked too
like what blind people dream about i've
heard that they dreamed about um
mostly it's the same as like a regular
dream but they just dream in like audio
and like you know smells and sounds and
things like that
um you know and maybe kind of like flash
like weird light and color and [ __ ] like
that
that's as far as i know that's you know
it also says [ __ ] reading what else
is [ __ ] [ __ ] fun and you'll know
when tom's invading someone's dream when
he yells growth in the middle of the
[Laughter]
just for something i said in my [ __ ]
sleep growth
[Laughter]
you used to say much crazier [ __ ] in
your sleep you don't really talk in your
sleep much anymore he used to talk in
his sleep so much
um just like all the time and i thought
and like loud like conversationally so i
thought he was talking to me like a lot
of the time i'd wake up saying i'm gonna
[ __ ] [ __ ] you i'm gonna [ __ ] kill
you i used to say well so well you still
say that every now and then but now you
just kind of mumble it you're just like
i'm a [ __ ] kid i'm a [ __ ] kid i'm
gonna kill you i hate you i hate you i
[ __ ] hate you yeah
and then i'm like
yeah me talking to ghost yeah he's not
i'm not like you better not be talking
to me
no a lot what's funny man as i told you
guys that when i'm asleep or i'm
dreaming
i'm [ __ ] in my 20s when i when i'm
when when i'm dreaming and i'm either in
the army or just got out
i don't know why
now sometimes in another but that's like
the most well that was like a high
intensity like yeah
yeah i'm usually talking to a [ __ ]
army buddy all right i'ma [ __ ] kill
you yeah
and here's the thing is i love that
[ __ ] usually you know what i
mean it's like it's like it's like one
of my brothers but we were constantly
mad at each other
you ex military guys know it but the
thing is it was like fun to be mad
it was part of the part of the game
just fighting over the fact that
his [ __ ] his [ __ ] rucksack layout
was [ __ ] up
during the inspection and the whole
[ __ ] platoon's getting punished
because you're [ __ ] stupid ass
it's that kind of [ __ ]
well you know or i [ __ ] woke up one
time [ __ ] asking my ex-wife this is
my ex-wife tiffany i said what kind of
bombs are those
and she's like i don't know
what kind of bombs yeah that's a pretty
good one what kind of bombs are those
and the thing is is that
in
in my dreams i was at [ __ ] south camp
in [ __ ] egypt
on the mfo mission
and i saw a whole [ __ ]
flight of [ __ ] f-15s coming in for a
landing
fully [ __ ] loaded up with [ __ ]
ordinance underneath on the pylons of
the wings and they had some huge ass
[ __ ] bombs
strapped onto those jets
and
i think it was [ __ ] sparks my friend
my friend sparks i'm still friends with
him tyler would love sparks he married a
black woman [ __ ] and [ __ ] made a
[ __ ] pretty ass black woman that was
his second wife
the sparks are standing next to me goes
and i go and i [ __ ] slap what kind of
[ __ ] bombs are those
and and he knew
but my ex-wife didn't know
well obviously but in my dreams he knew
yeah you know and he was telling me what
kind of bomb that was it's a 500 pound
bunker buster you know but
when he's telling me that at the same
time and i'm waking up my ex-wife is
going i i don't know
same kind of what
well i mean i kind of extrapolated what
you because like i'm i'm i was like half
asleep right yeah and then all of a
sudden you hear growth yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and i was just like oh for
christ's sake
i've known it for so long that it's like
at this point i just roll my eyes and
i'm just like whatever
whatever [ __ ] my life is [ __ ] my
life is [ __ ] up man
i just [ __ ] up gross growth
i was pissed
well i don't know if you sounded pissed
or if you i thought you sounded like
pulp yeah well yeah yeah that's what i
thought it's all the same
uh prepper pov says maybe the only
reason why it's people with great lives
who remember their reincarnation is
simply because it takes that intensive
life to remember
i have heard that uh put forward also it
seems to me that a lot of cases of
reincarnation especially stuff that you
get with like little kids like saying
stuff like remember when i died
um they'll usually say something like um
you know i remember like being shot
right here they'll have like a birthmark
that's like a big thing
um that they have a birthmark in the
place where the person that they're
supposedly reincarnated from like that's
where the wound was that killed them so
um you know and i was kind of thinking
about that earlier too because i was
seeing this one case where there was a
kid and i think he'd been he said he was
reincarnated as somebody that had been
like axe murdered or something like in
the next village over
and i was sitting there thinking why is
that so common like with all these kids
like saying that they got murdered in a
past life or hit by a car like that
there was one before
tilly on there
yeah it's like
that's being sparks
as sparks as when we were in korea
did you mess up my lighting again yeah
probably no it's all right it's all
right i'm gonna show another picture of
sparks
what the [ __ ] i had another good vision
from ephemera's park
but yeah i was i was thinking about that
um that it's like all these kids saying
they had these violent deaths and stuff
that's me as parks
i look tiny in next sport i was gonna
say he looks like
he looks like he could eat you yeah no
he's tall but he's not that much bigger
man it's just a [ __ ] weird way that
that [ __ ] is sucking
it almost looks like photoshopped yeah
it almost looks photoshopped but it
isn't sparks was my ag he carried the
spare barrel and all the [ __ ] ammo
[ __ ] carried a load about as
heavy as i did
but yeah so um
what was i saying so so yeah i was
thinking about that and then there was
one that was one on this documentary
that i saw about this kid that said he
was reincarnated like he got hit by a
car um and that he was 15 when he died
and they apparently found that kid's
grave and yeah the kid was 15 when he
was killed by a car and um you know he
the kid knew what kind of car it was and
everything and i was sitting there
thinking why is it that all these kids
are the same story and it's like they
said they seem to have like an
explanation on the show they said well
it's because like the deaths were
violent and sudden
there's sparks now and there's his wife
yeah
my boy
okay
tila says i don't know why people ask if
you dream in black and white or color i
dream of coloring yeah i thought
everyone did yeah i mean unless you you
know can't see colors for some reason i
mean i guess if you had some kind of
color blindness yeah then you probably
dream of black and white but i don't
think i've ever dreamt of black and
white that would be super weird because
you don't see the world in black and
white most people don't
so i don't understand why you would
so uh so let's talk about because you're
getting worn out and loopy right yeah
you need some growth i need some growth
it also says baby tom
[Laughter]
yeah
um so let's talk about this let's do
this last case like i said i had a
couple other ones but they weren't all
that complicated uh so let's talk about
this one because this is the one you
brought up earlier which is james
lininger
so this uh this story came out like in
the early 2000s
and it was like a huge
media sensation i guess
so this was a little kid named james
lininger
uh when he was two years old supposedly
he started waking up screaming when he
was two years old
and his parents asked him what the
matter was and he would always say
something to the effect of
uh airplane crash on fire little man
can't get out that's what he kept saying
now he was also excuse me he was also
like super obsessed with airplanes like
that was like his favorite toys
um and something that his parents said
that he did when he was three years old
was he would take his toy planes and he
would like go over them like a pilot
does during the pre-flight check you
know the main place so he would
be all like checking every all the stuff
on the plane
um he also apparently knew what a drop
tank was without ever being uh told
about it now
interestingly because his parents were
so interested in this kid
having apparent recurring nightmares
about an airplane crash being
obsessed with airplanes knowing a [ __ ]
ton about them probably more than a
little kid that age would normally know
they thought it was kind of unusual
so
they took him again to a therapist named
carol bowman
or bauman i guess it's bowman uh so they
he goes to her and it's like so the kid
uh you know and they say we'll tell tell
her which told us about all this plain
stuff
um
he told her
that he had that he was in world war ii
he was a pilot
he'd flown a corsair
and that it was attacked by japanese
forces and it crashed and he had died
now
he said these are the facts that he came
up with apparently
he said that he had uh that his plane
had taken off from a boat from an
aircraft carrier called natoma
um he also said somebody named jack
larson flew on his plane
um so his dad starts looking into it and
there's documentaries about this because
i saw something about i can't remember
if it was a whole documentary about this
or if it was just on one of those kind
of history channel
weird
shows um and it just might have been a
segment on that so his dad starts
looking into it um and he says indeed
the navy does have an aircraft carrier
called the natoma bay
and there was a guy named jack larson
uh living in the area at the time who
was around the same age
so uh this kid started signing his
drawings james three
and said that he was shot at um but that
he was killed during the battle of iwo
jima
um so his dad found out that there was a
guy named james houston jr
who was shot and killed at iwo jima
the plane was actually hit in the engine
which is something that
uh the kid would say all the time
and um
apparently you know so so apparently
that kind of checked out right
so all of this stuff kind of drew like a
lot of media attention so james
leininger who at this point is still a
little kid uh they start writing books
about him he's on tv he's on like all
these kind of uh shows you know proof of
reincarnation he knows all these details
that he couldn't possibly know all this
other stuff
so
as i said you know other than
the thing about it him being like really
really obsessed with airplanes when he's
a little kid which
is unusual but not that unusual for a
little boy i mean because i feel like a
lot of little boys are like super into
like cars or they're super into like
other things so
i don't know if it'd be that weird that
he actually knew
um the differences between like
different kinds of world war ii
airplanes
you know because i feel he got them as
presidents a lot he had like models of
them and he knew a lot about them right
even when he was like three years old
so
i don't know uh he so he what no i'm
just saying how big his sparks his
spark's about five nine
he's just they're just a funny pitcher
he's not that much bigger than me
and that was tally
we're i'm giving him an iv
he's flipping us off
[Laughter]
all right good
yeah so like i said even though it does
seem weird that he came up with i mean
he did come up with the name
uh the first name james for the pilot of
the plane but that was also his name so
again not that weird um
and
the fact that he came up with natoma
is kind of weird
um you know that being an actual
aircraft carrier although i will note
that as far as i'm aware
uh even though he said the plane that he
supposedly flew in was a corsair i don't
think that any corsairs actually
flew off of that aircraft carrier than
atoma bay just i wouldn't know um i i
don't think they did so
so he might have got it wrong i don't
really know
um so what ended up happening in this
case though even though like i said a
lot of the stuff about it sounded really
compelling like the kid said that he'd
i don't know if he
see that's the thing it's like so much
of this is like from the parents point
of view it's a little kid the little kid
is saying stuff you don't know how much
the parents are like start at like he
says weird [ __ ] and the parents start
asking him questions and you don't know
how leading those questions are you
don't know if the kid is just kind of
like making stuff up or just like saying
stuff that they think that the parents
want to hear or just pulling stuff out
their ass or whatever
and then maybe the parents
if they start believing hey maybe this
kid is a reincarnation of somebody we
should start looking into it and then
once they start looking into it if they
find some kind of match
then they might start massaging stuff
down that one direction see that's why
you got to watch because it's like that
seems like it would be really easy to
happen
and i kind of feel like maybe
this might have been what happened in
this situation
i feel like probably what happened
in this situation was that the little
kid
was having nightmares about a plane
crash
which
considering he was super super into
airplanes like like i said every
christmas every birthday he would always
get model airplanes he just loved
airplanes and he knew all about them
even world war ii ones he was like
superintendent damn
thank you oh thank you so much
a huge 50 super chat hey guys tuning
back in this episode just got off and
tuning in just got done watching your
vlad the impaler episode love tom's
opinion on it would love to have worked
with tom back then his fellow warlords
oh yeah we would have [ __ ] them all
i'm gonna [ __ ] them all up they'd have
been scared to cross us bro he didn't
put us all on spikes and make sure that
that [ __ ] pole was nice and dull
but rounded and great so you go like
right up here
right up your booty take a long time to
penetrate
a long time to penetrate that abdominal
wall you know what i mean just
just go by and you're interviewing them
how you doing
[Laughter]
once more okay
just hang around
i'll check on you tomorrow oh my god
yeah such a dad let's see how you feel
tomorrow okay it's just going farther
and farther up in there yeah
okay
see it's easy to break the body man how
do i feel i feel like a shish kebab
that's what i feel like the best the
worst is to break the mind you put a guy
in a box
that you can't really stretch out in
dick you know what i mean and there's a
hole in it one hole in the side that you
can't really look out
and you
turn him every now and then leave him in
there for a few days
and if he [ __ ] starts acting bad you
push his ass into put a chain on it you
push his ass into the swimming pool for
a while
let him get some water
then pull him back out leave him in
there for about a week or so see what he
feels like when you you know soften him
up
yeah then pull him out they probably
answer anything you want he'll tell you
anything
pro tip please don't do this to random
people
[Laughter]
no that [ __ ] mongolian [ __ ] death
coffin what they call that [ __ ]
yeah i remember you bringing that up
that'd be the worst
like i said that's that's terrible
there's people just sit around thinking
of yeah how can we make people like
suffer because that's not bad enough
what's what's worse than that mongolian
deck officer
yeah and they just sit around for ages
like thinking that's oh that's good but
how can we make it even more horrible
[Laughter]
yeah so
we so we saw a documentary about this
kid right
and it actually when i saw it like i
said i don't know if i really believe in
reincarnation or not because it seems
like a lot of this stuff is just kind of
like anecdotal or coincidence or
reaching you know a lot of it's kind of
reaching
um
this one actually sounded kind of
compelling
but the more you read about it
it seems like you're getting into a
similar kind of situation where i kind
of feel like it was just you had a
baseline of a little two-year-old kid
two three-year-old kid who loved
airplanes and starts having recurring
nightmares of plane crashes which
again not that's not an unusual i used
to have nightmares about plane crashes
and i'm not like even super into planes
i'm just like really scared of them like
a little scared of flying
so
somebody like a little kid that's really
into planes would probably have a lot of
recurring nightmares about planes and
probably some of them be about plane
crashes and they'd probably be like
really terrifying
so
it seems to me that he has these
recurring nightmares maybe his parents
you know
ask him about it and he says something
like oh there's a plane crash and i
can't get out a little man can't get out
and they think that's weird and then
maybe
in the same conversation or a different
conversation he brings up a specific
airplane
uh or you know maybe a world war ii
airplane at which point maybe his
parents start thinking hmm maybe there's
something to this or maybe he's
reincarnated and then they start
researching and then they find
somebody named james that died at that
battle in world war ii and then they
kind of like start
i kind of feel like it was that sort of
situation because like i said once it
started happening
they took him to a therapist again
and it really i don't think the
therapist wrote the book this time but
the therapist encouraged the parents to
write a book about it which they did
so
i just can't get away from like the
financial incentive because there is a
lot of money to be made
for these types of narratives
um and i'm not saying that the people
didn't actually believe them to start
out with it just seems like
if a lot of money is on the line then it
is it i mean it does behoove you to
embellish the story
to make a good book to make a compelling
narrative and you can even like fool
yourself into like really believing it
oh maybe the kid did say this that and
the other thing
even though maybe
he didn't say that maybe you interpreted
it like that or maybe you said it and he
you know what i mean thank you jeffy
jeffy art
so i don't know
it just seems to me that
that the stuff that he came up with
he just came up with the first name of
the pilot which was this coincidentally
the same as his name it was james
he said that he'd flown in the battle of
iwo jima okay that's weird but it's not
like that's a thing that nobody knows
about
um
he knew about world war ii planes he was
a little kid but he was into it i knew
about world war ii planes and tanks
that's what i'm saying a lot that's what
i mean and i think that they're saying
that they're talking about that like
it's a lot weirder than it is it's not
used to build little models and
everything yeah and that's what this kid
did little german yogg ponthurst and
[ __ ] like that he used to make all that
stuff world war ii stuff loved it yeah i
mean when i was little and i had like
interest in stuff it's like you know a
lot about that yeah you know what i mean
american boys back when i was a little
they liked the germans the little german
tanks the german planes they looked they
looked cooler they looked meaner
everything was all angular and more
modern
yeah you got sick of the sherman you
know the sherman was kind of round you
know well you always like stuff that's
different than what you're used to they
had like the [ __ ] king tiger and the
[ __ ] panther and they were just
really cool looking tanks you know
germans had good looking [ __ ]
they look good really good
well you know
they understood aesthetic
yeah
big time yeah
so you know that's one thing in their
favor i guess
i just so i don't know so i just kind of
feel like even though this is probably
in recent times this seems like one of
the more famous
reincarnation cases
again i just don't know
just because coincidentally
he came up with a couple things and the
fact that he came up with some [ __ ] that
didn't
match
like he came up with the word natoma
supposedly
and then they found out oh there's the
navy has an aircraft carrier called the
natoma bay but then the kid said that he
flew a corsair
allegedly and as far as i know their
corsairs there were no corsairs on the
nato ebay so
so some of the stuff that he said didn't
add up so i do kind of feel like this is
sort of maybe
a case of the kid
saying some random [ __ ] and then the
parents sort of like
embroidering it into a narrative that
maybe the kid wasn't
intending
i'm not saying that's the case it's just
that's what it seems like to me and the
fact that
they
i don't think they were intending to
make money out of it from the outset but
i do think that after they took the
after they came to believe that they
that the kid was reincarnated and then
they went to
one of these reincarnation therapists
like you know past life regression
people and that person said oh you
should write a book
and then they were like oh yeah okay
that's a good idea
because there's so much financial
incentive in this type of thing
i just feel like
there's just there's too much incentive
to like make things up
or
embroider things to sort of suit your
narrative i mean embellish
yeah yeah that's that's all i'm saying
so you know i'm not calling anybody a
liar i'm not saying anything like that
i'm just saying that maybe
maybe they're framing things in a way
that um is not exactly how it happened
i kind of think that
in this era a lot of the paranormal
stories that are handed down to us the
ones that have survived media contact
and the media at that time
loved a good story and they and
paranormal was a product that sold oh
yeah
so a lot of this stuff i think was
massaged
by the media that's kind of what i think
too into being
more impressive than it really was
yeah
oh yeah totally yeah and that's in a way
i think that's why a lot of stuff
because even the stories paranormal wise
uh that i remember
you know that made a big impact on me
when i was a kid like that turned up in
a lot of books like back in the 70s like
you know um what's that [ __ ] like
borley castle and borley band or what
the [ __ ] is it amityville was another
one yeah something like that burley
rectory that's what i was trying to
think of
stuff like that and i remember that
stuff sticking with me and it's like
when you read about it like in a book
back in the 70s you're just kind of like
holy [ __ ] that sounds amazing but then
like if you read about it nowadays like
all that stuff is like
totally been debunked and it was
debunked like a long time ago um they
were embellishing yeah you just didn't
hear about it because like because a lot
of the stuff back then it seemed like
like you said paranormal stuff was like
super hot
and you know ever and it sold like
zillions of copies so everybody wanted
to be like the next amityville horror or
the next this than the other i was a
little kid during that era you know and
there was a new age revival yeah and
paranormal was a part of the new age
revival and this goes to all those
[ __ ] universities like down at ucla
with all their parapsychology
departments educated people believed in
paranormal occurrences and psychic
abilities
i grew up believing in them and song
i think faith has a lot to do with it
mindset
um they never could prove anything and
then
most of the paranormal ghost type stuff
like amityville and [ __ ] was
highly suspect embellished
like i said the only one that i really
the only case that i've run across that
sounds like mine that i say yeah that's
most of this really happened you can
trust most of these witnesses and that
would be
the enfield poltergeist
cops sought newspaper reporters that
didn't know anything about the [ __ ] saw
objects thrown being thrown from nowhere
and things moving
without any real rhyme or reason but
then it got weirder and weirder voices
coming out of the girl but it's
i've given my opinions what i think that
is culture guys
recurrent spontaneous psychokinesis
it looks kind of like possession
sometimes
the
the person goes into fugue states and
[ __ ]
if there's [ __ ]
reincarnation and people remember in
past lives maybe it
might be something psychic picking up
things from the past
maybe inherited memories
but this whole idea of being born in a
new body and remembering your past life
not saying that
not saying that
i'm not saying that reincarnation maybe
isn't real
i just think being able to remember the
past life i don't i think highly
unlikely
highly unlikely
if even if
even if reincarnation is is real
it would be some kind of a system that
would prevent you from remembering past
lives
yeah so it may as well not even exist at
all if you don't remember it because you
wouldn't remember you know you wouldn't
be allowed to remember it that's not the
way of the force
that would be cheating
you have a new life so you don't
remember the old one
if there's reincarnation happening
i have to say too i think that people uh
probably not nowadays but i think
particularly back then i think people
put too much stock
into stuff people said when they were
under hypnosis as if that automatically
made it true i'm like people can
fantasize yeah under hypnosis also
fabricate and fabricate things
particularly if they have a hypnotist
who is asking them leading questions
yeah and i think that happens with a lot
of stories of you know like alien
abduction and stuff like that for
example if you go to a therapist or a
hypnotist who already believes in that
already believes in alien abduction
already believes in satanic cults
already believes in reincarnation
and
he thinks that maybe you're repressing
that information quote unquote
and he's gonna try and get it out of you
then he's gonna ask you questions that
are meant to do that and those are
leading questions and even when you're
under hypnosis
um
in a way you're kind of like more
suggestible so if you get the feeling
that the hypnotist is trying to get an
answer out of you then you will your
brain will
try to you know fabricate that
the answer that you think that they want
so
i i don't i don't know where people get
this it's a misconception that you can't
like make [ __ ] up when you're under
hypnosis that it's like some kind of
truth serum it's not
um you
you know it's arguable like
because i don't know if hypnosis is
really all that
scientifically sound i guess
but
you know people that
are apparently under hypnosis they can
totally just make [ __ ] up they don't
that doesn't mean that you're just like
it's not true serum you know what i'm
saying but i feel like people kind of
have that
like it like if you put somebody under
hypnosis and like sit and they do past
life or oh that must mean that that's
true because why would how would they
make that up if they're under hypnosis
danny's saying but in andyville they
left they left the house and left all
their stuff there that's what we're told
in the story we don't know if that's
actually what happened yeah i don't know
if they left all their stuff yeah they
probably did even if they did that's all
their stuff then they came back and got
it later and then they snuck back
or or their stuff wasn't worth anything
so they just like [ __ ] it i don't even
want to go back and get it like like i'm
leaving this desk while we move yeah
there's a lot of there's a lot of
evidence that amneville was actually
something drep dreamt up
way beforehand to sell books
well they even admitted that later
they said they just like drunk about a
bunch of wine and said hey well like i
said the murders did happen in the house
that was real so capitalizing on that
yeah i mean if you moved into i mean i'm
not gonna lie i don't i don't have that
many scruples if i moved into a house
where there was like a horrible multiple
murder that everybody knew about
i'd probably try to cash in by saying
this [ __ ] was haunted too you know i'm
not hating i'm just you know
i'm just saying that's probably what
they were doing i don't blame them
but
that's all it was i don't think the
house was haunted
you know
doesn't somebody live there now
i i mean i think the person that lives
there now has lived there for like
decades
and said nothing wrong wrong with that
house they changed like the out the
outside of it so it doesn't look the
same because they were tired of people
like driving by gawking at it
i wouldn't buy it for that reason just
because i don't want people coming up
standing in your yard all the time
and knocking on your door and [ __ ]
but
i wouldn't be afraid to live there
otherwise
because i don't really think it's
haunted i just wouldn't want like a
bunch like something that famous i
wouldn't want to live in somewhere that
famous
because you'd have people like camping
at your house and
zack baggins showing up on your [ __ ]
doorstep all the time and [ __ ] like that
[ __ ] that
yeah all right
sleeping you look like you're barely
holding on
oh
yeah you gonna live no we got yeah we
gotta
go back to the house tomorrow too i
gotta finish painting that new paint in
that bathroom and yeah
gotta put all the books in the
bookshelves put them together we'll ride
another motorcycle up there tomorrow oh
yeah that's a good idea yeah
has your new hat arrived tom no
no the leather daddy hat never [ __ ]
wrote that i'm still missing they even
[ __ ]
that's just coming all the way from the
[ __ ] or from the far east the orient
this shit's coming from [ __ ] thailand
they got all their origins from the
orient that [ __ ] [ __ ] yes okay 19th
19th century
[Laughter]
they got so many leather daddies up in
thailand that that they can't deliver
the [ __ ] on time they're fighting over
it they're like no don't let that one
out of the country
okay
oh i thought you were in the middle of a
sentence um i might have been
he might have had kids even though it's
gone i don't give a [ __ ] prepper pov
said when i was a kid i wrote on zack
baggins facebook wall saying that i was
going to ghost hunt at all the places he
did and he replied with that's the
spirit
at least he replied that was nice
you know he still seems kind of douchey
i don't know i don't know he just seems
like douchey
uh tammy says get some rest you two and
thanks for the live stream missed you
guys i know i felt so bad for like i i
wanted to do a show wednesday night but
man wednesday
well wednesday was the two u-haul
truck day wasn't it
and i spent all day painting
and my knees were just like
jelly
because of climbing up and down the
ladder and [ __ ] like that that was awful
yeah all right shut this [ __ ] down so
you guys next week
we'll either do i don't know we might
pop on on sunday because sunday is my
birthday
um
so
we might do something i might monday i
have to [ __ ] and then monday yeah if
we come on sunday we won't be able to
like drink too much because monday we
have
the big u-haul truck yeah that's gonna
take everything
but you'll have three more guys it won't
be just you yeah which will be nice uh
so if we do come on sunday it'll
probably just be in the afternoon and
we'll just like pop on for a few minutes
just to dick around and then hopefully
um i have the new studio set up by
wednesday so we can do a side tracks on
wednesday from the new house and show
everybody the office yeah i hope cause
they're coming to set up the internet on
tuesday
so if everything goes to plan because
i'm gonna go and set up and like hang
all the art and put all the books away
and chill like that tomorrow and uh
then we'll get everything moved over
there we'll see how it goes i'll i'll
keep you guys updated
but uh yeah thanks everybody for
having a friday night with us what are
you doing okay
he's just like he's like please yeah she
never shuts the [ __ ] down she's just
gonna talk i am i am gonna get away i'm
gonna go i just feel bad i feel bad
um all right saunder said haha it
sounded as if he was in the middle of
sense i waited too yeah so did i all
right so we will either see you guys
sunday or wednesday i will let you know
what's going on uh have a good weekend
up until we see you next time and
we will see you next time bye
ooh what was that i don't know something
hit the side of the house yeah